Guys, happy summer. Huh? How's the summer going? Right? It's so nice. It's so summery. It's really summery. So hot.
伙计们，夏天快乐。啊？夏天过得怎么样？对吧？太美好了。太有夏天的感觉了。真的太有夏天的感觉了。好热。
So summery we're doing a summer podcast. Yeah. This podcast today is going to be hot, hot, hot. Sorry about your mouth, Sean. Jesus, fuck dude. All right. Somebody punched you in the mouth before we said, oh no you're eating. Sorry, silly me. Oh my my god look at my microphone.
太有夏天的感觉了，所以我们要做一个夏季播客。耶。今天这个播客会非常非常热。肖恩，真为你嘴里的伤感到遗憾。天哪，操，老兄。好吧。在我们说之前，有人往你嘴上打了一拳，哦不，你在吃东西。抱歉，我真傻。哦，天哪，看看我的麦克风。
Yeah, there's two of them all over your microphone. Oh, welcome to Smarlet. Smarlet. Smarlet. Smarlet. Smarlet. Smarlet. Smarlet.
对，你的麦克风上到处都是两个。哦，欢迎来到 Smarlet。Smarlet。Smarlet。Smarlet。Smarlet。Smarlet。Smarlet。
Smarlet. Smarlet. Smarlet. Smarlet. Smarlet. Smarlet. Smarlet. Smarlet. Smarlet. Smarlet. Smarlet. Hi, JB. Sean.
Smarlet。Smarlet。Smarlet。Smarlet。Smarlet。Smarlet。Smarlet。Smarlet。Smarlet。Smarlet。Smarlet。嗨，JB。肖恩。
Hey, wait, let me just say this. Let me just say this. JB, it's 9.30. It's morning where you are, Sean and I are in the East Coast. Yeah. So, what time are you up today to get prepared for your day? I got up at seven today. You get up early every day.
嘿，等等，让我这么说吧。让我这么说吧。JB，现在是9点30分。你那边是早上，肖恩和我都在东海岸。耶。那么，你今天几点起床为这一天做准备的？我今天七点起床的。你每天都起得很早。
I do. Well seven's not early. No, it's usually six or six thirty. Today was a little bit later. I'm still battling. I'm long hauling something. It's not COVID. It's some sort of a head cold kind of really sinus thing, little coffee, little sniffly, like I beat it. And then 48
我确实起得早。好吧，七点不算早。不，通常是六点或六点半。今天稍微晚了一点。我还在跟病魔作斗争。我好像得了某种“长新冠”的后遗症。不是新冠。是某种严重的头部感冒、鼻窦炎之类的东西，喝点咖啡，有点流鼻涕，感觉我都快战胜它了。然后48
hours later, it came back. What is that? Well, you're not the first person in your house to beat it. Let's be honest. Yeah, yeah. The first song that's on over here. The good. that's true. Wait, so but it's not COVID you're not sick. I mean, I'm sick, but I'm not I haven't tested, but maybe I should. You know, it's so weird. I just got back. I go do physical therapy and a friend of mine at that office.
小时后，它又复发了。那是什么？好吧，你可不是家里第一个战胜它的人。老实说。对，对。这里播出的第一首歌。很好。那是真的。等等，所以但这不是新冠，你没生病。我是说，我生病了，但我没有测过，也许我应该测一下。你知道，太奇怪了。我刚回来。我去做了物理治疗，我在那家诊所的一个朋友。
He was trying to get a tick out of his daughter's arm and he squeezed the tick and it busted open and squirted in his eye and he got COVID from it. I swear to God, that's true story. Wait. He literally just told me like an hour ago. Hang on. So, COVID, so ticks carry COVID now too right next to their briefcase full of Lyme's disease? Yeah, no, I don't know.
他当时正试图从他女儿的胳膊上弄出一只蜱虫，结果他把蜱虫捏破了，然后汁液喷进他眼睛里，他因此感染了新冠。我发誓对上帝，这是个真事。等等。他 буквально（字面意思）在一个小时前刚告诉我。等一下。所以，蜱虫现在也携带新冠病毒了吗？就在他们装着莱姆病的公文包旁边？对，不，我不知道。
He said he was, he got home, his wife, nobody wanted to deal with the tick on his daughter's arm, so he squeezed it, and it squirted in his eye. Well, maybe he got COVID from his COVID-infested daughter instead of the tick. The tick can't carry two briefcases full of virus. It sounds like a pretty elaborate way to make an excuse for something that he's obviously leading like a double life.
他说他当时，他回到家，他老婆，谁都不想处理他女儿胳膊上的蜱虫，所以他捏了一下，然后汁液喷进他眼里。好吧，也许他是从他那满身新冠病毒的女儿那里感染的，而不是从蜱虫。蜱虫可装不下两个装满病毒的公文包。这听起来像是一个相当复杂的借口，用来掩饰某种他显然在过着双重生活的事实。
And so what he did was, he's like, yeah, he squeezed the tick and then the tick got on my eye, honey. Anyway, that's why I stayed in a home last long hauler. The tick squirted in his eye. By the way, it should be noted also that the JB that Amanda, you can't tell Amanda that story. She would look, she's so tick nervous. I know.
所以他做的是，他就像是，对，他捏了蜱虫，然后蜱虫弄到了我眼睛里，亲爱的。不管怎样，这就是为什么我一直待在家里像个长期患者。蜱虫喷进他眼里了。顺便说一下，还应该指出的是，JB，阿曼达，你不能把那个故事告诉阿曼达。她会看，她对蜱虫太敏感了。我知道。
Every time we talk about the East Coast, we talk about going to see friends, she gets very ticked off. She talks about going to visit friends in Martha's Vineyard or coming to CS out here and she's all about the ticks. You guys talk amongst yourselves, I need water. Okay. Get the first. He just gets up and goes, oh, I know.
每次我们谈论东海岸，谈论去看望朋友，她就会非常抓狂。她谈到去马撒 Vineyard 看望朋友或者来这边的海边，她满脑子都是蜱虫。你们大家自己聊会儿，我需要水。好的。先去拿吧。他站起来就走，哦，我懂。
He's coughing up a storm out there. He really is. Well, we're getting all of this. This is good. If you're a doctor and you're out there Please just listen to the thing. Yeah, boy You know you go eight million miles in the house like I do a little bit and you never get sick Um, I never see you sick. I saw you sick last year maybe one
他在外面咳得厉害。真的。好吧，我们正在获取所有这些。这很好。如果你是个医生而且你在收听，请只管听这个。天哪，你知道你在家里跑了八百万英里，像我一样稍微动一动，却从来不会生病。嗯，我从来没见你生病。我去年见你生病过，也许一次。
Yeah, I'm pretty good about I mean, I don't want to I don't want to um, template, but but I am pretty good about it. I mean, I don't want to I don't want to tempt fate, but but I am pretty good about Yeah, although Jason you never really get sick either Jason never gets sick either ever. No, I really don't I don't But you know, I'm fired up guys. I'm I'm I'm I'm excited to be smart-losing today. Are you guys are you guys ready to smart-less? Introducing it as verb are you getting your smartless on? I'm trying to fire up. I'm trying to fire up here, you know? Yeah.
对，我在这方面挺在行的——我是说，我不想——我不想触霉头，但我确实挺在行的。我是说，我不想——我不想触霉头，但我确实挺在行的——对，虽然杰森你其实也从来不生病。杰森也从来不生病，从来没有。不，我真的不，我没有。但你知道的，我很兴奋，伙计们。我很——我很——我很——我很高兴今天能录制 smartless。你们准备好了吗？你们准备好 smartless 了吗？把它作为动词介绍出来，你们正在开启 smartless 模式吗？我正在热身。我正在这里热身，你知道吗？对。
Hey, I'm glad that you're really excited to be here today and to be smartless and you mentioned because we have a guest because we don't just have a guest. We have an incredible guest today. Really? Yeah, well, because can we vote on that after the guest is revealed? Sure. Sure. But you know who has voted on this guest? Oh, America. America, the world. The Academy Awards has nominated this person three times and she's one. Titan up. For best actresses. So not by stood up. I've stood up all straight.
嘿，我很高兴你今天能来到这里并且非常兴奋能录制 smartless，你提到了，因为我们有一位嘉宾，因为我们不仅有一位嘉宾。我们今天有一位不可思议的嘉宾。真的吗？对，好吧，因为我们能在嘉宾揭晓后再投票吗？当然。当然。但你知道谁为这位嘉宾投过票吗？哦，美国。美国，全世界。奥斯卡金像奖曾三次提名这位女性，而她获奖了。振作起来。最佳女主角。所以我不是站着。我站得很直。
Nominating two other times. I mean, she's won Golden Globes. So she's won for three. She's won everything. She's won every possible award, been nominated multiple times for the, do you like the Golden Globes or the theater awards or Tony Awards or the theater awards? Is that what they're going to be? But Academy Award, winning Academy Award, once I start listening to her credits, you're going to go, oh yeah, and I know exactly what this is, because these are movies that you like through their movies like, am I gonna go?
另外两次提名。我是说，她赢过金球奖。所以她赢了三次。她赢了所有奖项。她赢得了所有可能的奖项，多次获得提名，你喜欢金球奖还是戏剧奖，或者托尼奖，还是戏剧奖？这就是他们要去的吗？但是奥斯卡奖，赢得奥斯卡奖，一旦我开始听她获得的荣誉，你就会说：“哦，对，我完全知道这是什么，”因为这些都是你喜欢的电影，通过它们的电影就像是，我会说吗？
Oh my God, you're so funny. Zero Dark 30, you're the Eyes of Tammy Faye, or- This is Jessica Chastain. This is Jessica Chastain. Wait, are you joking? Wait a minute. Yes.
天哪，你太搞笑了。猎杀本·拉登（Zero Dark 30）、塔米·菲的眼睛（The Eyes of Tammy Faye），或者——这是杰西卡·查斯坦。这是杰西卡·查斯坦。等等，你在开玩笑吗？等一下。是的。
Do I take it off now? Wait a minute, what? This is insane. This is crazy. This is crazy. I just it off now. What? This is insane. Well, no, I just thought you yesterday. I know it's insane. Congratulations, darling. Thank you, honey. I was really glad to have you.
我现在把它脱掉吗？等一下，什么？这太疯狂了。这太疯狂了。这太疯狂了。我刚才把它脱掉吗？什么？这太疯狂了。好吧，不，我昨天刚想到你。我知道这太疯狂了。恭喜你，亲爱的。谢谢你，亲爱的。我真的很高兴有你来。
Congratulations. No, I don't want to talk about it. Somebody's a big deal. Congratulations. It's a big, big, big, big team. I mean, how amazing to be on that journey with you the whole time. It was so great. We had one event where we were just mowling words to each other the whole time to try to
恭喜。不，我不想谈这个。有人是个大人物。恭喜。这是一个大、大、大、大团队。我是说，一路上能和你一起经历这段旅程是多么神奇。太棒了。我们有一个活动，我们在那里一直在用口型对彼此说话，试图
save our voices. And then I left. And then I left. And then you left, really. So, listener, we have not, we're taping this at a time that is just after Sean's win at the Tony Awards. So, we're trying not to talk about it because this is delayed, but given that. Oh, I get it, I'll call it another one.
保护我们的嗓子。然后我就走了。然后我就走了。然后你走了，真的。所以，听众朋友们，我们还没有，我们录制这个节目的时候，正值肖恩在托尼奖上获奖之后。所以，我们尽量不谈论这个，因为节目是延期播出的，但鉴于此。哦，我明白了，我再打一个。
I'll talk about it. Yeah, but since you guys are both, they're in the midst of it right now, it just ended, listen, or so. We apologize for being a little bit late. If you want to. But we can still talk about the experience that because it was weird, not the experience,
我会谈论它的。对，但既然你们两个都在其中，它刚刚结束，听众朋友们。如果我们有点迟到，我们深表歉意。如果你愿意的话。但我们仍然可以谈论这段经历，因为那很奇怪，不是这段经历，
but the theater experience for people who are listening, Jessica's theater was literally right next to mine. So every single day I got shot, Bob, I'd be like, there's Jessica Chastain starring in a doll's house and there's Johnny's starring. It was really cool. You guys have to hear each other show while you're performing.
而是对听众来说的剧院体验，杰西卡的剧院离我的剧院简直只有一步之遥。所以每天我一出场，鲍勃，我就会想：看，杰西卡·查斯坦在《玩偶之家》里主演，而强尼也在主演。这真的很酷。你们在演出时能听到对方的演出吗？
No, but the line to get in was always make it. It's like, you don't know if people were in line for your show or my show because it's always mixed up. Yeah, it was really cool. And people waiting outside afterwards. So my stage door was on 45th Street, which is the back of the theater. And your stage door was on 44th.
不，但是进去的队伍总是挤得满满的。就像，你不知道人们排队是看你的演出还是我的演出，因为总是混在一起。对，这真的很酷。人们在散场后在外面等待。所以我的舞台门在45街，那是剧院的背面。而你的舞台门在44街。
So my car was on the other side. And so every time I would leave, I would see all of you at the people waiting outside for you, it was very sweet. Oh, that's crazy. That's fun, right? You guys are like in this, your own little sort of in that world
所以我的车在另一边。因此每次我离开时，我都看到你们所有人都在外面等着你，这非常甜蜜。哦，这太疯狂了。这很有趣，对吧？你们就像在这个，你们自己的某种世界里，
and feeling like you're really part of a community and kind of in the trenches together in a way. And also, yeah, right. It was also nice to just have a comrade to go through it with, right? And do you guys have free tickets to each other's show or do you have to pay? Well, the thing is we can't see each other's show because we're performing at the same time. But now I close you guys the same days off.
觉得你们真的是社区的一部分，某种程度上一起在战壕里并肩作战。而且，是的，对。有志同道合的人一起经历这一切也挺好的，对吧？你们有彼此演出的免费票吗？还是得花钱？问题是，我们没法去看对方的演出，因为我们是在同一时间表演的。但现在我谢幕了，你们有同样的休息日。
You close. You've been saving it. We had Mondays off. I closed. And so now I mean, I'm after a week into heat. She'll be there tonight. Sean. Yeah, a week.
你谢幕了。你一直留着呢。我们周一休息。我谢幕了。所以现在我的意思是，我演出一周后就要去大溪地了。她今晚就会去。肖恩。对，一周。
I'm gonna come see everything. A week into Heady, that sounds so good. Yeah, I need a complete reversal of location. I'm just, I'm just, That's about the opposite. Although that does sound like a play as well, a week into Heady, that could be the one act, right? Yeah.
我要去看所有的演出。演出一周后去大溪地，听起来太棒了。对，我需要彻底转换一下地点。我只是，我只是，这简直是截然相反。虽然这听起来也很像一出戏，演出一周后去大溪地，那可以是一幕剧，对吧？对。
Jessica's returned to Broadway. Maybe that's just be the title of my autobi well. A Weakens Tahiti. That could be one act, right? Yeah. Jessica's returned to Broadway. Maybe that's just me the title of my autobiography. Weakens Tahiti. Have you been there before it? It's Tahiti? I have, but I went, I went, a friend of mine invited me during COVID. So who had any had both there.
杰西卡重返百老汇。也许这就可以作为我的自传标题。演出一周后去大溪地。那可以是一幕剧，对吧？对。杰西卡重返百老汇。也许这就可以作为我自传的标题。演出一周后去大溪地。你以前去过那里吗？是大溪地吗？去过，但我去的时候，一个朋友在疫情期间邀请了我。所以谁都有过。
So I basically was just in the water of Tahiti. But we didn't really have to. Very nice. You're going to strike land this time. I am. I'm very excited. Are you exhausted from doing H.O.Z. Oh my God.'re going to strike land this time. I am. I'm very excited. Are you exhausted from doing H.O.D.
所以我基本上就待在大溪地的大海里。不过我们其实不用。太好了。你这次要脚踏实地了。是的。我非常兴奋。你演 H.O.Z. 累坏了吗？天哪。你这次要脚踏实地了。是的。我非常兴奋。你演 H.O.D. 累坏了吗？
Oh my God. I don't know if you can tell. My voice is like, I'm done. I've been taking all these immunity medicines and stuff because I just feel like any second my body is going to go all right now it's the time. Let me have a kick your ass. Well let me ask you. I'm going to ask you that because we've been going through this with Sean.
天哪。我不知道你能不能看出来。我的嗓子就像是，我受够了。我一直在吃各种免疫药物之类的东西，因为我觉得随时我的身体都会说“好了，现在是时候了。让我来踢你的屁股”。那让我问你。我要问你这个，因为我们一直在和肖恩一起经历这个。
I feel like we're all on this journey with Sean Jason. But, just can tell me if you have, and this actually goes to both of you guys, you know that what you're gonna about to embark on when you're gonna do a play on Broadway is gonna be really demanding in a lot of different ways, but especially physically. And so you prep yourself, I imagine. You get yourself up, you're like, okay, here we go, we're gonna do this. I'm gonna be fine. And then what is the point you, when you start doing it, you go like, I imagine. Like you get yourself up, you're like, okay, here we go, we're gonna do this. I'm gonna be fine. And then what is the point you,
我觉得我们都在和肖恩、杰森一起经历这段旅程。但是，杰西卡，告诉我你是否有过——这实际上适用于你们俩——你知道当你准备在百老汇演一出戏时，它在很多方面都会非常具有挑战性，尤其是体力上。所以我想你会做心理准备。你让自己振作起来，你会想：好吧，我们要开始了，我们要演这个了。我会没事的。然后当你开始演的时候，在哪个时间点你会觉得——我想象一下。就像你让自己振作起来，你会想：好吧，我们要开始了，我们要演这个了。我会没事的。然后当你开始演的时候，在哪个时间点你会——
when you start doing it, you go like, oh my God, this is way worse than I thought. Is it a week? Is it two weeks? Is it a month? Oh gosh. I mean, after the first week of previews for me, at one point I went to the director and I said,
当你开始演的时候，你会想：哦，天哪，这比我想象的要糟得多。是一周吗？是两周吗？是一个月吗？哦，天哪。我是说，对我来说，在第一周的预演之后，有一次我去找导演说：
I don't think this is sustainable. I don't understand this level of motion. I don't think this is sustainable. I don't understand this level of motion. I don't think it's sustainable. And he's like, no, you can do it. That's what's just his response to every time. I was like, are you sure? You could do it. How long did you do your show?
我觉得这不可持续。我无法理解这种情绪的强度。我觉得这不可持续。我无法理解这种情绪的强度。我觉得这不可持续。然后他说：“不，你行的。”这就是他每次对我的回答。我当时想：你确定吗？你行的。你演出持续了多久？
We did 137 performances. But my show also, it was pretty emotional. There was heavy crying for an hour each show. So it was, it definitely is not something. We're gonna do it again somewhere. I'll have another life next year. But in very much shorter runs, because there was a lose my mind.
我们演了137场。但我的演出也相当情绪化。每场演出都有一个小时的沉痛哭泣。所以这绝对不是一件……我们以后还会找地方再演的。我明年会开启另一段生活。但剧期会短得多，因为我真的要疯了。
Can you flick the switch on crying pretty easy or is it a big process for you? Some people it's easy. No, I'm like, you know, the kids when they do, I always think about this with my kids, is when I see them playing, they absolutely believe what they're doing. They're so in it when they're, at school they call it dramatic play.
你能很轻松地开启哭泣的开关吗？还是说这需要一个漫长的情绪酝酿过程？对有些人来说很容易。不，我觉得就像，你知道，孩子们在玩耍的时候——我总是通过我的孩子们想到这一点——当我看到他们在玩时，他们绝对相信他们正在做的事情。他们完全沉浸其中，在学校里这被称为戏剧游戏。
And I kind of feel like that's just what happens is, I'm in the scene and then I just believe it's happening. Right, and the tears come. Sometimes, sometimes if the mood is right, Scottie and I call it role play. So, I'm trying to. Oh, that's definitely for a different show. Definitely for a different show.
我觉得这正是所发生的事情：我身处场景中，然后我只管相信它正在发生。没错，眼泪就流出来了。有时，如果气氛正好，斯科特和我把它叫做角色扮演。所以，我在努力。哦，那绝对是另一个节目了。绝对是另一个节目了。
And then you believe it's happening, Sean. I believe it. I do. I didn't order this pizza. Well, what do you mean? Are you not hungry? I didn't say you could just come into my apartment, but you're here now.
然后你相信它正在发生，肖恩。我相信。我真的信。我没点这个披萨。好吧，什么意思？你难道不饿吗？我没说你可以随便进我公寓，但你现在在这儿了。
But this is the meat lovers pizza. I can't use it. I love meat. Do you, do you, do you find that like you spend all this emotion like you're on stage, you're falling for an hour, and then you get home into your life and stuff happens and you've got no emotion left for anything else? Like, no, in fact, I'm like the opposite,
但这可是食肉动物披萨。我吃不了。我爱吃肉。你，你，你觉得——就像你把所有的情绪都倾注在舞台上，演了一个小时的悲剧，然后你回到家里开始日常生活，发生了一些事情，而你已经没有多余的情绪去应付其他任何事情了？就像，不，事实上，我正好相反，
which probably my poor family and friends have been so sweet with me. I just become so kind of raw that I'm like a little bit like a baby, where things that shouldn't make me emotional, make me emotional. And it's just, I start to feel like I'm losing my mind. Which is why now I'm looking forward to another Zero Dark 30, like playing a character
这可能让我可怜的家人和朋友对我非常包容。我变得如此敏感脆弱，就像一个小婴儿一样，那些本不该让我情绪波动的事情却让我情绪波动了。我开始觉得自己快要疯了。这就是为什么现在我期待着另一部《猎杀本·拉登》那样的作品，去扮演一个
who really doesn't, am I allowed to cuss on this? I mean, I've heard before. Oh, yeah. Well, I'm just doesn't give a shit. Just just like, I'm, you know, she's just walking through. I need to play that next. I love that you asked if you could cuss.
真的不——我能在节目里说脏话吗？我是说，以前听过。哦，是的。好吧，我只是说——她根本不在乎。就像——我，你知道的，她只是走来走去。我接下来需要演那种角色。我喜欢你问能不能说脏话。
You're the first nice, you're the first nice, respectful guest we've had. Was it always part of your life growing up too, or you, and as a kid, were you in high school? It was. My grandma took me to see a play when I was seven. I didn't have the easiest of, you know, childhoods in some sense, because we were, you know, I was raised by a single mom and she really struggled a lot financially.
你是我见过的第一个这么好、这么尊重人的嘉宾。在你成长过程中，这也一直是生活的一部分吗？还是你在上高中时就……是的。我七岁时我奶奶带我去看了一场戏。在某种程度上，我的童年并不轻松，因为我们，你知道的，我是由单亲妈妈抚养长大的，她在经济上非常挣扎。
And I was kind of an angry kid a lot. And so my grandma took me to this show at the Music Circus Theater in Sacramento, California. It was Joseph and the Amazing Technicolor Dreamcoat. Awesome, girl. And there was a, and she told me she, because it was a big deal. It was a professional show.
而且我小时候是个挺生气的孩子。所以，我奶奶带我去了加利福尼亚州萨克拉门托的音乐马戏剧院看了一场演出。那是《约瑟夫的神奇彩衣》（Joseph and the Amazing Technicolor Dreamcoat）。太棒了，女孩。那里有一个，而且她告诉我，因为这很不寻常。这是一场专业演出。
She kept saying that they were, this was their job, these actors. And then it started and there was a little girl on stage and I was like, oh, this is what I am. It wasn't a sense of like, this is what I wanna be. I was like, oh, this is what I'm gonna do. And, and then I just spent like my poor mom was like, oh, this is what I'm gonna do and And then I just spent like my poor mom was like, can you bring me to LA to audition for commercials?
她不停地说那些人是，这些演员这就是他们的职业。然后演出开始了，舞台上有一个小女孩，当时我就想：哦，这就是我。这不是那种“我想成为这样的人”的感觉。我当时的想法是：哦，这就是我要做的事。然后我就开始——我可怜的妈妈当时就像是——哦，这就是我要做的事，然后我就开始——我可怜的妈妈当时就像是：你能带我去洛杉矶试镜拍广告吗？
Wait, how old were you when you were in grandma took you to that? Seven. Yeah, because I saw I saw a chorus line when I was 10 and I always wish I'd seen it earlier like when I was like I don't know five six, six, seven, eight. Oh my God. Longer fall. I don't know what to say about that. You can set themself up and hit it. I was so happy about that. He's like, I got a one-man bully ball, too. He loves it and then he spikes it himself.
等等，你奶奶带你去看那个的时候你多大？七岁。对，因为我十岁时看过《歌舞线上》（A Chorus Line），我一直希望自己能更早看到它，比如在我大概五、六、七、八岁的时候。天哪。彻底倒台。我不知道该对这个说什么。你可以自己设好陷阱然后踩进去。他对此太高兴了。就像：我自己弄了个单人排球，他超喜欢，然后自己扣球。
But I do want to say, you know what's interesting in the Christmas meet, how many kids their first introduction to theater is Joseph in the Technicolor Code? I know, right? But I do want to say, you know what's interesting? It occurs to me. How many kids their first introduction to theater is Joseph and the technicaler code? I know, right? Right. I mean, that's like the sort of the game. That's one of the, one of the, because it's like safe for high schools to do and it's safe for like kids. Yeah, and kids, a lot of kids go and see, they'll go see with their family or they'll
不过我想说，你知道圣诞肉类大餐里最有趣的是什么吗？有多少孩子的戏剧启蒙是《约瑟夫的神奇彩衣》？我懂，对吧？但我确实想说，你知道什么很有趣吗？我突然想到了。有多少孩子的戏剧启蒙是《约瑟夫的神奇彩衣》？我懂，对吧？对。我的意思是，那就像是某种常规剧目。那是其中之一，因为高中演这个很安全，对孩子们来说也很安全。对，孩子们，很多孩子会去看，他们会和家人一起去，或者会
go see with their school or like in my question is, do we need to update what that is? Yeah. I don't even remember what happens in the show. That's the sad thing. I think that's the one and only time I ever saw it. You know what? It was the first play I think I saw. Oh, really?
和学校一起去，比如我的问题是：我们需要更新那个剧目吗？对。我甚至不记得剧里发生了什么。可悲的是，我想那是我唯一一次看那个剧。你知道吗？那好像是我看过的第一部戏剧。哦，真的吗？
It was the reason I ever saw it. I saw it in black and white though. Oh, no. What was the one with the roller skating? Starlight Express? Yeah. That one with that one? Yeah. I think? Yeah. That one, the way back when? Yeah, I think that was my first one.
那是我看过的第一部。不过我是看黑白版的。哦，不。那个玩轮滑的是什么剧？《星光快车》（Starlight Express）？对。就是那个吗？对。我想是的？对。那个，很久以前的？对，我想那是我的第一部。
And then the real hats. Then there were some roller skating. Yeah. Just a little cat. And a lot of siblings, Jess, in your family, are just you? Yeah, two boys and two girls. Oh, wow. And Vendee also.
然后真正的帽子。然后是一些轮滑。对。只是一只小猫。杰斯，你家里有很多兄弟姐妹，还是只有你？对，两个男孩两个女孩。哦，哇。还有温迪也是。
I was the only one. You're one of five. Yeah, one of five. And you're youngest? My youngest brother is 24. So are you in the middle? I'm the oldest. She's older. Oh, you're the oldest. Sorry Sorry, sorry. Yeah, now what now so so so then the acting was it something that came because you started so early Did it was it something that came very naturally to you or did you start training early on? It's something
我是唯一的。你是五个孩子之一。对，五个之一。你是最小的？我最小的弟弟24岁。所以你在中间？我是老大。她是姐姐。哦，你是老大。抱歉，抱歉，抱歉。对，现在，那么，那么——然后表演，这是因为你开始得太早所以自然而然就会的，还是你很早就开始接受训练了？这是一件
Because I went to public schools. I just remember like they would assign the plays in schools to the people who got really good grades and I think it could. Great. So it's always like the person on the side or holding the tree or whatever. And then we got to the middle. Holding the tree. Not even the tree, just holding the tree. I know, just like holding it up.
因为我上的是公立学校。我只记得学校里会把戏剧分给那些成绩很好的学生，我觉得这很好。太棒了。所以总是有人站在旁边，或者扮演一棵树之类的。然后我们到了中学——扮演一棵树。甚至不是树，只是拿着树。我知道，就像把它举着。
And then we got to middle school and it was the first time we started like, you know, having a class, the elective, where you could choose what class you wanted and I chose the drama class. And then, you know, that's when I really started doing stuff. I actually won a monologue competition and I have a little trophy for it. And I actually had, it's like that to me
然后我们上了中学，那是我们第一次开始有了一门课，选修课，你可以选择你想上什么课，我选了戏剧课。然后，你知道的，那才是我真正开始做事情的时候。我其实赢过一个独白比赛，我还拿了一个小奖杯。我甚至还有——对我来说，那
is one of the most, is the sweetest things in my house because I think I was like 12 or 13 and it was a big deal. It was for some, I was like, wow, I actually, people think I'm good. I'm good. I'm good. Yeah, that was important.
是我家里最甜蜜的事情之一，因为我想我当时大概12或13岁，这算是一件大事。那是为了一些，我当时想：哇，原来人们真的觉得我很优秀。我很棒。我很棒。对，那很重要。
You know what's interesting though? So you grew up in Sacramento, not exactly like a hotbed for theater and that, right? But you go, you see that play, how do you make that leap from being a little girl in Sacramento who sees a plane and that, right? But, but you go, you see that play, like how do you make that leap from being a little girl in Sacramento who sees a play and is super nervous saying that's me to, I don't wanna jump all the way
你知道有趣的地方在哪里吗？你在萨克拉门托长大，那里可算不上戏剧的温床，对吧？但你去看了那部戏剧，你如何从一个在萨克拉门托看戏的小女孩——对吧？但你去看了那部戏剧，你如何从一个在萨克拉门托看戏、紧张得要命、说着“那是我”的小女孩，跨越到——我不想一下子跳跃
to becoming an Academy, Academy Award-winning actress, but like, what's that first movie you're like in Sacramento, like I gotta go from here to what? Yeah. Well, I mean, I was going, I had no idea, because I don't know anyone in the industry. Yeah. And again, it was kind of a tough situation, you know,
到成为一个奥斯卡获奖女演员，但——你脑子里第一部想演的电影是什么，在萨克拉门托的时候，你觉得我得从这儿去到什么地方？对。嗯，我的意思是，我当时根本不知道，因为我不认识业内任何人。对。而且，再次声明，那里的情况有点艰难，你知道的，
at home, and I was doing a lot of community theater and working at Sac City College doing like their Shakespeare. I think I did, I did, I mean, the shrew and all of this stuff. And then I actually dropped out of high school. She's crazy. And then I actually dropped out of high school. She's crazy. I might, I dropped out of high school.
在家里，我当时在做很多社区剧院的工作，还在萨克拉门托城市学院（Sac City College）演过莎士比亚的剧。我想我演过，我是说，《驯悍记》（The Trewing of the Shrew）以及所有这些。然后我实际上从高中辍学了。她太疯狂了。然后我实际上从高中辍学了。她太疯狂了。我可能，我从高中辍学了。
I had to take PE twice. And I think I didn't graduate, because I missed, because I failed PE twice. I failed PE twice. I failed PE twice. Because I had no interest in like doing pull ups. And like, I just had like no. And I was reading, you know, Shakespeare in cutting-class reaches. I was, I was such a like, no. And I was reading Shakespeare in cutting-class...
我体育课得重修两次。我想我没能毕业，因为我错过了，因为我体育课挂了两次。我体育课挂了两次。我体育课挂了两次。因为我对做引体向上毫无兴趣。而且我只是——完全没有兴趣。我当时在读，你知道的，在逃课期间读莎士比亚。我当时就是这样一个——完全不。我当时在逃课期间读莎士比亚……我简直是个书呆子。哇。
I was such a nerd. Wow. I'm probably, yeah, I can't even understand it, but I dropped out and then I started working and I did some regional theater. I played Juliet at theater works in Silicon Valley. And then the guy who was playing Romeo got into Juilliard. And I was like, I don't think he's that much better than me.
我可能，是的，我甚至无法理解，但我辍学了，然后我开始工作，演了一些地区剧院的戏。我在硅谷剧院工场（TheaterWorks）演过《罗密欧与朱丽叶》里的朱丽叶。然后扮演罗密欧的那家伙考进了茱莉亚学院。当时我就想：我觉得他没比我好多少。
Something he could go. And so I did. Oh, wow, great. Yeah, that's amazing. It's changed my mind. Wait, going back to high school, I remember, I remember in my high school, there was a thing called, like the debate team called, it was called forensics.
他都能去。所以我也去了。哦，哇，太棒了。对，太惊人了。这改变了我的想法。等等，回到高中，我记得，我记得在我的高中，有一种东西叫做，辩论队叫做“法医学”（forensics）。
I did that. Of course you did, because like everybody, like the debate team called, it was called forensics. I did that. Of course you did, because like everybody, I knew in high school, I didn't do it. And it freaked me out because people were, What is it, Sean? It's like when you are in a debate team and they teach you how to debate, like improv debate, right?
我参加过。你当然参加过，因为就像每个人，辩论队叫法医学。我参加过。你当然参加过，因为就像每个人，我认识的高中生里，我没参加过。这把我吓坏了，因为人们在——肖恩，那是什么？就像你加入辩论队，他们教你如何辩论，即兴辩论，对吧？
And people. No, they don't. Yes, they do. Oh, sorry. And I freaked me out. It was my first experience watching kids my age face a wall and talk to the wall because they would be rehearsing. Yeah.
然后人们。不，他们不教。不，他们教的。哦，抱歉。这把我吓坏了。这是我第一次看到和我同龄的孩子面对着墙壁自言自语，因为他们在排练。对。
I was like, are they crazy? Like, it was like a mental institution. And also different voices because you play different characters and they're near-rate and they're young. Yeah, it was wild. How funny, by the by the way for the listener how funny and you guys can test this are and weird are Jason just said audition lobby is like when you remember going to like you do it like auditioning to a casting office and everybody's holding their sides and people are like find like a little corner or they're sitting on the edge of a chair and
我当时想：他们疯了吗？这就像个精神病院。而且还有不同的声音，因为你要扮演不同的角色，而且语速飞快，而且他们还很年轻。对，太疯狂了。真搞笑，顺便说一下，对于听众来说，多搞笑啊，你们可以验证这一点，杰森刚才说的试镜大厅是什么样子的，就像你记得去那种地方——你去做试镜，去选角办公室，每个人手里都拿着剧本（sides），人们会找一个小角落，或者坐在椅子边上，
they're just going I don't know. It's talking over their face. They're being going over with practicing their faces. Yeah their faces. I don't know if they're being... Yeah. ...going over what they're practicing their faces. Yeah, their faces, their thing that they... Like, their little angles, their little beat that they've got on the thing that they're going to do. And then, you get older and you do it like the four of us as a profession, and then you find yourself doing it, and you're like,
然后他们就在那儿……对着脸念念叨叨。他们在练习自己的表情。对，他们的表情。我不知道他们是不是在……对……琢磨他们练习的表情。对，他们的表情，他们……就像，他们的小角度，他们为要演的那场戏准备的节奏。然后，随着你长大，我们四个人把这当成了职业，接着你发现自己也在这么做，然后你会想：
Oh, now it's not so weird, because I'm doing it. I don't know. Yeah. You know? Yeah. And we will be right back. Smartlet's get support from Helix. I'll say we get support. I get support on my dusk lux mattress.
哦，现在这没那么奇怪了，因为我也在这么做。我不知道。对吧？对。我们马上回来。Smartless 得到了 Helix 的赞助支持。我得说我们得到了支持。我在我的 Dusk Lux 床垫上得到了支持。
Boy do I sleep great. I sleep like a king. I sleep like a sleeping queen. I sleep like a king. I sleep like a sleeping queen. I sleep like all the royalty because I have a Helix Dusk Lux mattress. The Helix lineup offers 20 unique mattresses, including the award-winning Lux collection, the newly released Helix Elite collection, a mattress designed for big and tall sleepers, and even a mattress made just for kids. Let's talk about the new High-end Helix Elite Collection.
天哪，我睡得太好了。我睡得像个国王。我睡得像个沉睡的女王。我睡得像个国王。我睡得像个沉睡的女王。我睡得像所有皇室成员一样，因为我有 Helix Dusk Lux 床垫。Helix 系列提供 20 种独特的床垫，包括屡获殊荣的 Lux 系列、新发布的 Helix Elite 系列、专为高大身材睡眠者设计的床垫，甚至还有专为儿童制造的床垫。让我们来聊聊全新的高端 Helix Elite 系列。
It includes six different mattress models, each tailored for specific sleep positions, and firmness preferences. Nervous about buying a mattress online? Whaa! Don't be! The Helix Sleep Quiz takes into account your individual sleep preferences to match you and your partner. Yay!
它包括六种不同的床垫型号，每一种都专为特定的睡眠姿势和软硬偏好量身定制。在线购买床垫感到紧张？哇！大可不必！Helix 睡眠测试会考虑您的个人睡眠偏好，为您和您的伴侣进行匹配。耶！
With the perfect mattress for you and your personalized mattresses ship straight to your door free of charge. Plus, Helix mattresses all come with a 10 or 15 year warranty depending on the model. Helix is offering 20% of all mattress orders and two free pillows for our listeners. Go to helixleap.com slash smartless. This is their best offer yet and it won't last long. With helix, better sleep starts now. Smartless is sponsored by Smart Water.
为您量身定制最完美的床垫，并免费送货上门。此外，根据型号的不同，Helix 床垫均享有 10 年或 15 年的保修服务。Helix 为我们的听众提供所有床垫订单 8 折优惠以及两个免费枕头。请访问 helixsleep.com/smartless。这是他们迄今为止最好的优惠，而且不会持续太久。有了 Helix，更好的睡眠从现在开始。Smartless 由 Smartwater 赞助。
So, Scotty and I took a little helicopter flight and we did a little tour in the air of New York City. We flew right by the Stancho Liberty with the thing that she holds. What is that, the torch? And we got really close and it was kind of amazing. But of course, I thought, well, we're really high up. What happens when you're high up in altitude, whether it's a planar helicopter, you get dehydrated.
所以，斯科特和我坐了一趟小直升机，我们在纽约市上空进行了一次空中观光。我们从自由女神像旁边飞过，看着她手里拿的东西。那是什么，火炬？我们靠得非常近，这感觉有点不可思议。但当然，我想，我们飞得真高啊。当你在高海拔地区时会发生什么，无论是飞机还是直升机，你都会脱水。
So every single time I'm in a helicopter, I always bring smart water. Here in the podcast, we are smartless, but we're not smart water less. Smart water is 100% vapor distilled with a pure crisp taste, it's pH balanced, and offers added electrolytes for taste. And it says here, we're not allowed to say that smart water makes you smarter, but we can say it's for sipping while you're listening to your favorite podcast, of course. Keep it smart with smart water. [♪ Music playing in background, but they've figured out solutions for the problems you're facing.
所以每次我坐直升机，我总是带着 Smartwater。在这个播客里，我们是 smartless，但我们绝不离开 Smartwater。Smartwater 是 100% 气蒸蒸馏而成的，口感纯净清爽，酸碱平衡，并添加了电解质以提升口感。这里写着，我们不能说 Smartwater 能让你变聪明，但我们可以说它是你在收听最喜欢的播客时抿一口的绝佳选择，当然。用 Smartwater 保持聪明。[♪ 背景音乐播放中，但他们已经为你面临的问题找到了解决方案。
See for yourself. Right now, you can try them for free at ziprecruiter.com slash smart list. Zip Recruiter is ready to tackle your recruiting challenges. To reach more of the right people, Zip Recruiter posts your job to 100 plus job sites. Need to hire ASAP, Zip Recruiter's smart technology finds great matches for your job sooner. Want first dibs on talent? Zippercuders lets you invite the most qualified people to apply to your job. Plus Zippercuders pricing is straightforward, no surprise costs. Team up with a hiring partner who understands what you need. Zippercuders, four out of five employees who post on
亲自来看看吧。现在你可以在 ziprecruiter.com/smartlist 免费试用他们。ZipRecruiter 已准备好应对你的招聘挑战。为了接触到更多合适的人选，ZipRecruiter 会将你的职位发布到 100 多个招聘网站上。需要尽快招人？ZipRecruiter 的智能技术能更早地为你的职位找到绝佳匹配。想抢先获得人才？ZipRecruiter 让你能够邀请最符合条件的人来申请你的职位。此外，ZipRecruiter 的定价简单明了，绝无隐藏费用。与真正理解你需求的招聘合作伙伴并肩作战。ZipRecruiter，在
Zippercuders get a quality candidate within the first day. Just go to this exclusive web address to try Zip Recruiter for free. Zip Recruiter.com slash smartless. Again, that's ziprecruiter.com slash S-M-A-R-T-L-E-S-S Zip Recruiter, the smartest way to hire. And now back to the show. So Jessica, so you were all in.
ZipRecruiter 上发布职位的雇主中，五分之四的人在第一天内就能获得优质候选人。只需访问这个专属网址即可免费试用 ZipRecruiter。ZipRecruiter.com/smartless。再次强调，网址是 ziprecruiter.com/S-M-A-R-T-L-E-S-S。ZipRecruiter，最聪明的招聘方式。现在回到节目中。所以杰克逊，所以你全力以赴了。
So you go to, you go to Julia, there was no other sort of like, you didn't go to like a college where you had, well, I'll, I'll major in drama, but I'll minor in business or something like that. But J.P., I'll interrupt to say also, not just that, Jessica, you got, didn't you get the Robin Williams scholarship at Julia as well? Oh, wow. So that was actually a huge deal financially for us, because he went to Julia hard and he was from everyone,
所以你去，你去了茱莉亚，没有其他那类选择——你没有去那种大学，在那里你可能会想，嗯，我主修戏剧，但我辅修商业什么的。不过 JB，我要打断一下，不仅仅是这样，杰西卡，你当时不是还获得了茱莉亚学院的罗宾·威廉姆斯奖学金吗？哦，哇。所以这对我们的经济状况来说实际上是一笔巨款，因为他曾就读于茱莉亚学院，而且从所有人的
the talks about him, such a generous human being. And he gave the scholarship every two years and it basically paid for everything. Didn't just pay for tuition. It paid for my apartment. It paid for me to fly back and forth to go see my family at Christmas. It paid for food. It was a ginormous.
评价来看，他是一个如此慷慨大度的人。他每两年颁发一次这个奖学金，基本上支付了所有费用。不仅仅是学费。它支付了我的公寓租金。它支付了我圣诞节飞回家看望家人的机票。它支付了伙食费。这是一笔巨大的开支。
He was an incredibly generous guy. Did you guys know Robin a little bit? I met him when I shook his hand once. He was such a, I had the pleasure of spending a little bit of time with them over the years a few times and he was an incredibly generous, sweet, sweet guy. I mean, and anytime you check in with anybody who knows him, so it doesn't surprise me that he did, I mean, that's so thoughtful. And as a young person and going to do this thing and going to New York, those kinds of
他是一个极其慷慨的人。你们以前认识罗宾吗？我见过他，我曾跟他握过手。他真的是一个——我有幸在这些年里与他们有过几次短暂的相处，他是一个极其慷慨、非常非常甜美的人。我是说，任何向认识他的人打听过的人都会知道，所以他对做这种事我一点也不意外，我是说，太贴心了。作为一个年轻人，去从事这项事业并前往纽约，那种开销
expenses are just tough to cover. Yeah, for anybody. Yeah. And to have somebody do that. So then you get to go to Juilliard. And then how did they assign that scholarship? Obviously, those that need the economic assistance are the candidates, but I imagine that there's some sort
实在是难以承担。是的，对任何人来说都是如此。能有人这样做。然后你去了茱莉亚学院。然后他们是如何分配这个奖学金的？显然，那些需要经济援助的人是候选人，但我想肯定有某种
of, is there like an act off? Just saying to the city, supporting a vet. You're like glad supporting event? Yeah. Or like gladiators? Yeah. Was there any sort of, I was acting often, I was like 12. I don't think so.
选拔赛吗？杰西卡对着城市大喊，支持老兵。你就像是在支持老兵？对，还是像角斗士一样？对。有什么类似的东西吗？我有过表演选拔，我当时12岁。我不这么认为。
I mean, the first two years, it was a lot of, you know, loans, you know, like those Sally May loans. I was just, I borrowed so much money to try to sustain it. I was in the dorm. And then the scholarship went to your final two years. Gotcha.
我是说，前两年，有很多，你知道的，贷款，你知道的，就像那些萨莉·梅（Sallie Mae）贷款。我借了好多钱来维持生活。我住在宿舍里。然后奖学金是在最后两年发放的。明白了。
And I think it just was based on the work you had done your first two years. So I played, I don't know, I played Arcaudan and the Seagal, my final project, my second year, and they went over well with the teachers, and maybe that might have had something to do with it. I don't know, but it was a big deal. So I'm sorry, I may have missed this, I apologize. You're one of five kids. Yeah. And it was at a single mom or single mom. Yeah. Same exact same situation. No. Yeah, five kids. It didn't go out in fairness. Did your mom have two eyes Jessica? Because this is where it's not gorgeous. Well, well, well, well, well, well, well, well, well.
我想这只是根据你在前两年所做的工作来决定的。所以我在第二年的期末项目中演了阿尔卡迪亚和海鸥，老师们对我的评价很好，也许这与此有关。我不知道，但这确实是一件大事。所以抱歉，我可能漏掉了这一点，非常抱歉。你是五个孩子之一。对，而且是单亲妈妈抚养的吗？单亲妈妈。对。完全一样的情况。没有。对，五个孩子。没有公开公平竞争。你妈妈有两只眼睛吗，杰西卡？因为这就是不好笑的地方。好吧，好吧，好吧，好吧，好吧，好吧，好吧，好吧，好吧。
Please answer the question if you have two eyes. Were you the eldest in your family, Sean? Youngest. Youngest. Youngest. Yeah, she had to keep an eye on five. Guys, I got a lot. It's been a year and a half for this.
如果你有两只眼睛，请回答这个问题。肖恩，你是家里老大吗？老幺。老幺。老幺。对，她得盯着五个呢。伙计们，我有好多。这节目录了一年半了。
Wait, Jay B, did you get that text I sent you about when my sister posted? Did you get the one I crying emoji? Well, just going to my mom and you go, you go well. Sean's mom had one eye her whole life. And we've talked about it extensively on the program. But when Sean won the Tony is his sister put on Facebook my mom It should be so happy. She'd be crying her eye out. Oh my God You know you're other laugh or cry Jessica. Yeah, that's really good
等等，JB，你收到我发的那个短信了吗？关于我姐姐发的信息？你收到那个带哭泣表情符号的了嘛？好吧，说到我妈妈，然后你说，你就会说，肖恩的妈妈一辈子只有一只眼。我们在节目里广泛讨论过这件事。但当肖恩赢得托尼奖时，他姐姐在脸书上发文说：“我妈妈会高兴极了。她会哭得眼睛都快掉下来了。”哦，天哪，你不知道该笑还是该哭，杰西卡。对，这真的很棒。
That's interesting though, so you guys do have very similar experiences. Yeah, in that way and then you both end up in the theater Why didn't you go to Julia artard? Jesus, just go with you. What's wrong with you? Because I can't spell it. G-U. What's that feeling like when you come out? So you go to Juilliard, which is arguably the most sort of acclaimed, certainly in America, theater school.
不过这很有趣，所以你们俩确实有非常相似的经历。是的，在这方面，然后你们俩最后都进入了戏剧界。你当时为什么没去茱莉亚学院？天哪，你跟她走一趟不就完了。你有什么毛病？因为我不会拼写。G-U。当你从那里毕业时，那是一种什么样的感觉？所以你去了茱莉亚学院，可以说是最具声誉的，当然是在美国，戏剧学校。
You come out of their art school, you come out of there. And is the feeling like, all right, I'm just ready to go, and everything's just gonna offer us or gonna fly at me. Like, I was wondering what that experience is like coming out of an acting school in that way. Well, I was very lucky I got a deal. So my class was the first one to do a LA showcase.
你从他们的艺术学校毕业，你从那里走出来。那种感觉是：好了，我准备好出发了，一切都会主动找上门来，或者机会都会向我飞来？我是说，我很想知道以那种方式从表演学校毕业是什么体验。好吧，我很幸运，我拿到了一个合约。所以我的班级是第一届去洛杉矶进行汇报演出（showcase）的。
And actually, I brought it to the administration because I had come to Los Angeles this summer before the fourth year and found out that other schools were doing it. And then I really, really pushed for it. And we got it. So by coming out here and doing the Showcase, I got from that, I got a deal with John Wells. And so it was very helpful. It was like right out of the bat, I had someone kind of in my corner. And then I could, you know, do plays in New York. Like I worked at Playwrights Horizon.
其实是我向校方提议的，因为我在第四年开始前的那个夏天来到了洛杉矶，发现其他学校都在这么做。然后我真的、真的极力争取。我们成功了。所以通过来到这里并进行汇报演出，我从那里面得到了与约翰·韦尔斯（John Wells）合作的合约。所以这非常有帮助。刚一出道，我身边就有人在支持我。然后我就可以，你知道的，在纽约演话剧。比如我在剧作家地平线（Playwrights Horizons）工作过。
And I'd fly back and forth to Los Angeles to audition for his shows and whatnot. But I made that money last for like four years. That's amazing because I think we'll like what you're kind of saying is like, and to me too, growing up, you think Julia is the pinnacle of all. It is the best of the best. And you just just like me, it means just assumes
我会飞回洛杉矶去为他的节目之类的进行试镜。但我把那笔钱省着用，维持了大约四年。这太棒了，因为我觉得我们——就像你刚才说的，对我来说也是一样，在成长过程中，你认为茱莉亚学院是所有一切的巅峰。它是最好中的最好。然后你就——就像我一样，这意味着你只是默认了
every single person that graduates from Julia and whether it's music or art or theater or whatever gets a job. You know, and it's like, so it's wild to... Yeah, like graduation day, they're like, all right, here are the parts that we're gonna be handing out today. Right, that's a...
从茱莉亚学院毕业的每个人，无论是音乐、艺术、戏剧还是别的什么，都能找到工作。你知道的，这真的是……对啊，就像毕业那天，他们会说：“好啦，这是我们今天准备颁发给你们的角色。”对，那是……
You're doing this thing for Paramount, you're gonna be shooting it. You're doing it, right? Right, yeah. So Jessica, I mean, like, is it, you seem like you're still very aware of your upbringings and your journey and that you're fully appreciative of where you are
你在为派拉蒙做这个项目，你要去拍它。你在做，对吧？对，没错。所以杰西卡，我是说，你似乎对自己的成长背景和心路历程仍然非常清楚，而且你完全感激自己现在所处的位置。
and like, it, thank God, it doesn't seem like it's lost on you that your whole life, you have seen this path, you've wanted this path, you've trained for it, you've, you've respected what it's going to take to get there, you've done everything that you should, and you, you've done it. I mean, you're there. You've got an Oscar, you're like the most respected actors in the world. That's got to feel fantastic. And I don't want to embarrass you. And I don't expect you to sort of say, yeah, yeah, it's awesome. But how about like, is your mom still with us? Or your siblings?
谢天谢地，你似乎没有忘记这一点：你这一生中一直看到这条道路，你渴望这条道路，你为之接受过训练，你尊重到达那里所需要付出的努力，你做了所有应该做的事，而且你做到了。我是说，你做到了。你拿了奥斯卡，你就像是世界上最受尊敬的演员之一。这感觉一定棒极了。我可不想让你尴尬。我也不是指望你会说：“对啊，对啊，这太棒了。”不过话说回来，你妈妈还在吗？还有你的兄弟姐妹呢？
Yeah. And my grandma took my grandma to the Tony's the other night. No way. So they have the spirit of speltering Tony. the other night. No way. So they have the I'm just a spell-tring Tony. She's like when's Joseph coming out? Are they do they do they help you take your your your very very deserving smell the roses every once in a while? Yes, completely but also too. I think because it doesn't feel that far away and you know a lot
对的。我前几天还带我奶奶去参加了托尼奖。真的假的？所以他们有……我只是个在念托尼奖的……她甚至说：“约瑟夫什么时候出来？”他们会帮你……让你偶尔去闻闻玫瑰花香吗？完全会，但同时我也觉得，因为这一切感觉并没有那么遥远，而且你知道，我生活中的很大一部分其实都是……
of my life was a little bit of like okay I know what I'm going to do. I don't know how I'm gonna get there exactly But I'm very aware of the people who show me a lot of kindness and actually Jason I don't even think you remember oh I'm sorry. Let me just start with I'm sorry. No, no, I'm gonna to talk about how kind you were. I have addiction issues, Jess. No, no, no, no. Jason, don't admit too much. OK, sorry. I'm telling you, no, the charges. My boyfriend was.
好吧，我知道我要做什么。我虽然不知道具体该怎么到达那里，但我非常清楚那些对展现出极大善意的人。其实杰森，我觉得你甚至都不记得……哦，对不起。让我先说声对不起。不，不，我等会儿要说你有多善良。我有毒瘾，杰西卡。不，不，不，不。杰森，别承认太多。好吧，对不起。我跟你说，不，这些指控……我男朋友是……
Ned Benson. Ned Benson. So you do remember? I love him. You took me to a Dodgers game with Ned. Yes. It was the first time I was sitting there. And I was like, I have Ned.
内德·本森。内德·本森。所以你还记得？我爱他。你带我和内德一起去过道奇队的一场比赛。是的。那是我第一次坐在那里。当时我就觉得，我有内德……
I mean, I was so close to the players. And I'd never experienced anything like that before. When was it? It was so kind. 20 years ago? Yeah, a long time ago. Yeah. Before anyone even cared anything about anything.
我是说，我离球员们那么近。我以前从未经历过那种事。那是什么时候？太贴心了。20年前？对，好久以前了。对。在任何人甚至都不在乎任何事之前。
Or me or Ned. Jason didn't care. He didn't even bring it up. He's been talking for half an hour and he had to bring it up. How embarrassing. You wonder if people remember things because I should have talked to you for one second. You don't know what the guest wants to talk about. What is her show?
或者不在乎我和内德。杰森才不在乎呢。他甚至都没提起这事。他已经聊了半个小时了，结果还是不得不提。多尴尬啊。你会怀疑人们是否还记得这些事，因为我本该跟你聊上一秒钟的。你根本不知道嘉宾想聊什么。她的节目是什么？
By the way, he just did us a favor because he did that is shows a sign of respect that adjacent that he didn't just bring the Dodgers up and talk about them for 20 minutes because he would love to do that or net or net or net love net. So Jessica, because because of we had similar backgrounds to you, is that part of, you know, some people think it's not cool to talk about drive or ambition, but everybody has it who has any, even the smallest amount of success.
顺便说一句，他刚才其实是在帮我们，因为他这么做表现出了一种尊重——杰森没有直接把道奇队的事拿出来讲个20分钟，尽管他其实很想那么做——还有内德，或者内德，或者内德，爱内德。所以杰西卡，因为我们有着和你相似的背景，这是不是……你知道的，有些人觉得谈论驱动力或野心不够酷，但任何取得哪怕一点点成功的人，内心其实都有这种驱动力。
You have to have some drive. So, why does that get a bad rap? Like, you're supposed to want things in this life. Yeah, and then you're supposed, then you get mocked for actually pursuing them. And then if you don't, then you're called lazy unmotivated and entitled. I wonder if it's that people mistake drive ambition for ego, for like narcissism. When reality, like my drive and ambition comes from, I mean, this we're going to get real deep here.
你必须得有某种驱动力。所以，为什么这会留下不好的名声呢？好像在这个世上你就该有所渴望似的。对，然后当你真正去追求它们时，你又会被嘲笑。但如果你不这么做，你就会被说成是懒惰、没有动力、还有着严重的权利意识。我在想，是不是人们把驱动力和野心误当成了自我，当成了自恋。但实际上，我的驱动力和野心来自于……我是说，我们现在要探讨得很深刻了。
Maybe it comes from a sense of like wanting to be better. And maybe that also comes from my upbringing, a sense of like I want to be better than, I, you know, I just wanna get better every day. Just to see how much better you can get. It's just challenging yourself, right? Yeah, and it's not like I want it all. It's just I wanna do a good job.
也许它来自于一种想要变得更好的渴望。也许这也源于我的成长背景，有一种“我想变得更好”的感觉，我只是想让自己每天都变得更好。看看自己究竟能变得多优秀。这其实就是在挑战自我，对吧？对啊，并不是说我什么都想要。我只是想把工作做好。
See if I can do more or take out more. Or yeah, I mean, this all falls under the heading of challenge yourself, probably, right? I mean, and if you're not, I suspect everybody here is the same in this way that, for instance, a constantly like, you know, I'm just going to retire. I'm just too tired and stuff. And then I think like, I couldn say, like, you know, I'm just going to retire. I'm just too tired of this stuff. And then I think like, I couldn't do it for six hours because it's not that I get bored,
看看我是不是能做得更多，或者承担更多。或者，对，这一切大概都可以归结为“挑战自我”这个主题，对吧？我是说，如果你没有这么做，我猜这里的每个人在这个方面都是一样的。比如我经常会说：“好吧，我要退休了。我只是太累了之类的话。”然后我想……比如我可以说：“好吧，我要退休了。我只是对这些东西感到太累了。”接着我又觉得，我连六个小时都坚持不下来，因为并不是说我会觉得无聊……
but I just want to, that's the whole purpose of life is to engage and to challenge yourself and to be constantly, right? I mean, yeah. And hopefully you're constantly in a state of having the courage to ask for more. Because oftentimes I've been in a place of, oh my God, I can't thank God I'm not being asked to bear any responsibility because I just don't have the ego or the confidence to take it on right now.
而是我只想……生活的全部目的就是参与其中，挑战自我，并且不断地……对吧？我是说，对。希望你也能不断地拥有要求更多的勇气。因为很多时候，我都曾处于这样一种状态：噢天哪，谢天谢地，没有人要求我承担任何责任，因为我现在的自我意识或自信根本不足以让我挑起这个担子。
Like I've been in that place a lot of times in my life. And if you find yourself in a place of like, no, please let the phone ring. I want the ball. Yeah. That's a great place to be. That's a gift and that's a positive. Jay, Sean, you want the ball?
就像我生命中有很多次都处于那种状态。如果你发现自己处于一种“不，请让电话响吧，我想要这个机会”的状态。是的。那真是一个太棒的状态了。那是一种天赋，也是一件积极的事。杰，肖恩，你想要这个机会吗？
Sure, both. I hate the couple of them. Jessica, let me ask you this, because I've been going through this lately, which is, you know, I'm 53 and I think you look great. You have made it. I was kind of a listen. Thank you. I was sneaking too short.
当然，两个都想要。我讨厌你们俩。杰西卡，我来问你这个，因为我最近一直在经历这种状态，也就是——你知道的，我53岁了，我觉得你看起来棒极了。你成功了。我刚才其实是在……谢谢你。我刚刚有点语无伦次。
There was a play of 10. I mean, you can tell that you hang out, you work out a lot. Yeah, it's real. The tan is real. That's not a cheap one, you know? No, this one's new, by the way. I think it's worse. I can tell it.
有一个评分是10分。我是说，你能看得出来你经常出入，经常健身。对，这是真的。这肤色是真的。那可不是什么便宜货，你知道的？不，这个是新晒的，顺便说一句。我觉得它更糟。我能看出来。
I think I'll get this one. I forget how he got this one. But I've been having this thing lately, where I'm working on stuff for doing things, and I've been able to say, I think I was saying to you, Jay, maybe the other day, that I can admit that I'm working on stuff for doing things and I've been able to say, I think I was saying to you, Jay, maybe the other day that I can admit that I'm like scared and because I'm about to do something, you know, that is maybe out of my comfort zone
我想我会选这个。我都忘了我是怎么弄到这个的。但我最近一直有这种感觉：我在为某些事情努力，在做一些事情，而且我能够说出口——我想我那天可能对你说过，杰——我能够承认自己其实很害怕，因为我即将去做某事……
a little bit. And I think when I was a younger man, I had a tougher time admitting that where I wasn't involved enough or I wasn't mature enough. And I wonder if you have those things, because you do a lot of things that are very challenging, certainly when it comes to your work. Do you have those moments now as you get older,
你知道的，那可能稍微有点超出我的舒适区。我觉得在我更年轻的时候，我更难承认这一点，那时候我还不够投入，或者不够成熟。我想知道你是否有过这种感受，因为你做了很多极具挑战性的事情，尤其是在你的工作方面。当你渐渐变老时，你现在也会有这样的时刻吗？
where you go like, yeah, I'm scared about this, or I'm nervous. Not that you're not gonna do it, but that you recognize that, do you have that at all? Are you asking me? Yeah. Yes, I care what they think. I mean, it's also the sense of...
你会觉得自己说：“是的，我对这个感到害怕，或者我很紧张。”并不是说你不会去做，而是你意识到了这一点，你完全有这种感觉吗？你是在问我吗？对。是的，我在乎别人的看法。我是说，这也是一种感觉……
Because I don't feel far away from how I grew up, I always want to feel like I'm grateful and thankful. So I don't... I find laziness, the... In my... Who I am, I find it to be the worst trait. And I also have difficulty with lazy... You know, if someone's super lazy, I have, I find it to be the worst trait. And I also have difficulty with lazy, you know, if someone's super lazy,
因为我觉得自己离过去的成长经历并不遥远，所以我总是希望自己能保持感激和感恩。所以我不……在我的性格中，在我骨子里，我发现懒惰是最糟糕的特质。而且我对懒惰的人也……你知道的，如果有人超级懒惰，我发现这是最糟糕的特质。而且对于懒惰……你知道的，如果有人超级懒惰，
I have difficulty being around it because I feel like, wow, you could do so much. You could do, you know, there's all these incredible things out there that you could be a part of if you just showed up, show up for yourself and show, you know, for others. And so I have that in me where it's, it's like, even if I'm really scared, if there's someone
我和他们在一起会觉得很吃力，因为我觉得，哇，你本可以做成那么多事的。你本可以……你知道的，只要你肯露面，只要你愿意为自己露面，也为别人露面，外面有那么多不可思议的事情等着你参与其中。所以我的骨子里也有这种特质：哪怕我真的很害怕，只要有某个人
that believes that I can do it, I don't want to let them down. And I really want to push myself. And I don't want to allow any kind of nerves or fear. And especially especially with Tammy Faye, I had so much fear of like, oh my god, this is such a swing. And I'm going to get made fun of. But this idea of like, I can't like allow,
相信我能做到，我就不想让他们失望。我真的想好好逼自己一把。我不想让任何紧张或恐惧占上风。尤其是……尤其是拍《塔米·菲的眼睛》时，我心里有那么多的恐惧，觉得“天哪，这次尝试跨度太大了，大家一定会笑话我的”。但这种想法……我不能允许……
and that's ego actually, if you allow your ego to stop you from doing something. Because it's all about how you're perceived. But do you think, yeah. That's interesting. But at the same time, but is it ego, is it ego, I'm asking, I'm actually like wondering. Maybe you guys jump in.
这其实就是自负，如果你允许自己的自负阻止你去尝试某件事的话。因为这全都是关于你如何被别人看待。但你觉得，对。这很有趣。但与此同时，但这算是自负吗？这算是自负吗？我在问，我其实是在琢磨。也许你们可以插话。
If is it ego to acknowledge that fear? Meaning a good, a good thing or a bad thing? Yeah, like just to go like, hey, this is something that's really challenging and I need and I'm just recognizing it. Maybe it would take, I think it would take a healthy ego to admit that something is presenting a challenge to you. And I think, but it is also that same ego that's going to be the fuel to push you through it.
承认这种恐惧算不算自负？这意味着这是一件好事还是一件坏事？对，就好像是在说：“嘿，这是一件极具挑战性的事情，我需要它，而且我只是意识到了这一点。”也许需要一个健康的自负，才能承认某件事对你构成了挑战。而且我认为，也正是这种相同的自负，将成为推着你跨过这道坎的动力。
And that, and that you shouldn't be nervous about the fact that you're not feeling the confidence to run into the situation because the confidence lives on the backside of the accomplishment. It's like, no, the confidence will be there once I get through it. That's what I'm going to earn. So don't take it as a false negative. It would be a false negative to think, oh God, I can't handle this because I'm not feeling confident going into it.
而且……而且你不应该因为自己缺乏冲进这种局面的自信而感到紧张，因为自信其实是在完成之后的另一面。这就好比：“不，等我熬过这一关，自信自然就有了。那才是我通过努力赢得的。”所以不要把它当作一个虚假的负面信号。如果你心里想：“天哪，我应付不了这个，因为我进去的时候一点自信都没有”，那才是一个虚假的负面信号。
The confidence lives after it, I think, for me. For sure, for sure. Totally. Very well said. If you're confident while you're doing it, if I am, I find that the work is probably bad. It's not. Yeah, yeah.
对我而言，自信是在事情完成之后才出现的。肯定的，肯定的。完全赞同。说得太好了。如果你在做这件事的时候信心满满，如果我也有这种感觉，那我发现这份工作大概率要砸。不会的。对，对。
You're so excited. It's a good gas. Yeah, when you're like, yeah, I got this, man. Exactly. is a good, good gas. Yeah, when you're like, yeah, I got this, man. Yeah, exactly. I am petrified before every single performance. Is that true? Is that true? Petrified, that makes you great.
你太兴奋了。这倒是个好油门。对，当你觉得“太棒了，这事儿我拿下了，老兄”的时候。没错。是个好……好油门。对，当你觉得“太棒了，这事儿我拿下了，老兄”的时候。对，没错。我每次演出前都吓得要死。真的吗？真的吗？吓得半死，这才能让你变得伟大。
Well, I don't know about that, but I just like, the Tony winner. No, no, no, I'm being, I think. It makes you great. Yeah, well, thanks, but I'm just saying it's true. I don't know if it does. So I'm agreeing with you, Sean. It both, thanks, but I'm just saying it's true. I don't know if it does. So I'm agreeing with you, Sean.
好吧，这个我可不知道，不过我只是觉得……托尼奖得主。不，不，不，我是说……这能让你变得伟大。好吧，谢谢，不过我只是说这是真的。我不知道它是不是真的。所以我是在附和你的观点，肖恩。它们既是……谢谢，不过我只是说这是真的。我不知道它是不是真的。所以我是在附和你的观点，肖恩。
We've seen the show. No, but, oh wait, I wanted to, so Jessica, like back to like, when I was a kid, I was just, I'm asking you, if you felt the same thing, when I was a kid, I had, you know, my dad laughed at my mom was always working. She was great, but you were kind of left apparent yourself. And so you kind of are given this option of figuring this life out on your own,
我们看过这部剧。不，但是……哦等等，我本来想说的是——所以杰西卡，就像回到……当我还是个孩子的时候，我只是……我在问你，你是否有过同样的感受：当我还是个孩子的时候，你知道的，我爸爸笑了，我妈妈一直在工作。她很棒，但你基本上是被迫自己抚养自己。所以你基本上被赋予了两种选择：要么自己摸索着过完这辈子，
or kind of just taking a back seat to it. And I think that decision at some point was like, wait a minute, no one's, I have to figure, I have to take care of myself and figure this out for myself. So, and I've taken that into adulthood, where it's just like, and I think for better or worse, sometimes worse, I don't stop. Like, I've got to get food on the table.
要么就对此退居其次，逆来顺受。我觉得当时在某一个时刻，我做出的决定是：“等一下，没有人……我必须自己摸索，我必须照顾好自己，为自己把这一切搞清楚。”所以，我把这种心态带到了成年后，那就是……而且我觉得，无论好坏，有时候往往是坏的一面，我根本停不下来。就像我必须把饭端上桌。
I've got to eat, I've got it, because there's been so many times when I didn't have food and I didn't have, you know, so it's a fear as much as it is a drive. Wow, we have very similar upbringing, Sean. It's crazy. It should be noted, Sean, you feed yourself the same way you did when you were 11, which is just too much salad potato
我必须得吃，我必须……因为曾经有太多次我吃不饱饭，你知道的……所以这既是一种恐惧，也是一种驱动力。哇，我们的成长经历太相似了，肖恩。太疯狂了。值得一提的是，肖恩，你现在喂饱自己的方式和你11岁时一模一样，那就是吃太多的沙拉、薯片，然后不停地奔跑。别忘了还有那个包。
chips and so running. Don't forget about the back. It's so true. By the way, on my corner of my building, there is an ice cream truck every single day in a fruit stand. I passed that fruit stand. Yeah. Let me even look at the poor guy. Yeah, do you guys find Jessica and Sean that you're not great at asking for help, that you're not great at sort of deferring or delegating because you've had to sort of be self-sufficient for so long? Yeah, I do. I tend to do everything into the point where then I get completely overwhelmed.
太真实了。顺便说一句，在我那栋楼的拐角处，每天都有一辆冰激凌车和一个水果摊。我路过那个水果摊。对。我甚至都不敢看那个可怜的人一眼。对，杰西卡和肖恩，你们有没有发现自己其实很不擅长寻求帮助，很不擅长推卸责任或授权，因为你们太长时间以来都必须靠自己独立支撑？是的，我确实如此。我往往会把所有事情都揽下来，直到自己被彻底压垮。
And I think because I was the oldest child too, there was a sense of having to take care of my, I want to almost hit my kids, my siblings. You know, my mom would bartend, and it would be like us there, you know. So it was really a sense of trying to figure out, you know, how everyone was gonna be okay. So I think I also have that now, even as, this is too much.
我想这也是因为我是家里最大的孩子，有一种必须照顾我的……我几乎想说照顾我的孩子，照顾我的兄弟姐妹的责任感。你知道的，我妈妈以前在酒吧兼职，我们就在那里，你知道的。所以这真是一种试图弄清楚……你知道的，怎样才能让每个人都平安无事的心理。所以我觉得我把这种习惯也带到了现在，尽管有时候……这真的太多了。
And my friends were like, okay, settle down, Chastain. But I try to like, someone has an issue, I'm like, okay, let's solve it. Let's figure it out. And I've had to understand that everyone has the dignity of their own process. And I allow them to have their own life. I'm so similar.
我的朋友们就会说：“好了，冷静点，查斯坦。”但我总是试图……如果有人遇到了问题，我就会说：“好的，我们来解决它。我们来把它搞定。”我不得不去理解一件事：每个人都有按自己的方式去经历人生的尊严。我必须允许他们过自己的生活。我也太像了。
And these guys can attest to it. I'm like, they're like, hey, should we? I'm on it. I'm like, I'll get it. I'll take care of it. Sean, we'll get an email about some work thing and it'll be like a long email that'll have maybe 12 points to it that most people would be like, let's talk about it and think about it maybe for 24 hours.
这些家伙都可以作证。我会说……他们会说：“嘿，我们要不要……？”我来搞定。我会说：“我来弄。我来处理。”肖恩，我们会收到一封关于某项工作事务的邮件，那可能是一封长邮件，里面大概有12个要点，大多数人看到都会觉得“我们讨论一下吧，或者考虑个24小时再说”。
I'm not even going to read this email yet. Sean, within five minutes is like, yes and no, and yes and we should do this. I'm like, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, yes. Sean within five minutes is like, yes and no. And yes, and we should do this. I'm like, well, well, well, well, well, well, well, well, well, well, well, well, well, well, well, well, well, well, well, well, well, well, well, well, well, well, well, well, well, well, well, well, well, well, well, well, well, well, well, well, well, well, well, well, well, well, well, well, well, well, well, well, well, well, well, well, well, well, well, well, well, well, well, well, well, well, well, well, well, well, well, well, well, well, well, well, well, well, well, well, well, well, well, well, well, No, I love the greatest. Yeah. We'll be right back.
我甚至都不会立刻去读这封邮件。肖恩在五分钟内就会回复：“行，这个不行；行，这个可以，我们应该这么做。”我就想：“哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，行。”肖恩在五分钟内就会回复：“行，这个不行；行，这个可以，我们应该这么做。”我就想：“哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，我才想起来，我的男朋友是……内德·本森。内德·本森。所以你还记得？我爱他。你带我和内德一起去过道奇队的一场比赛。是的。那是我第一次坐在那里。当时我就觉得，我有内德。我是说，我离球员们那么近。我以前从未经历过那种事。那是什么时候？太贴心了。20年前？对，好久以前了。对。在任何人甚至都不在乎任何事之前。或者不在乎我和内德。杰森才不在乎呢。他甚至都没提起这事。他已经聊了半个小时了，结果还是不得不提。多尴尬啊。你会怀疑人们是否还记得这些事，因为我本该跟你聊上一秒钟的。你根本不知道嘉宾想聊什么。她的节目是什么？顺便说一句，他刚才其实是在帮我们，因为他这么做表现出了一种尊重——杰森没有直接把道奇队的事拿出来讲个20分钟，尽管他其实很想那么做——还有内德，或者内德，或者内德，爱内德。所以杰西卡，因为我们有着和你相似的背景，这是不是……你知道的，有些人觉得谈论驱动力或野心不够酷，但任何取得哪怕一点点成功的人，内心其实都有这种驱动力。你必须得有某种驱动力。所以，为什么这会留下不好的名声呢？好像在这个世上你就该有所渴望似的。对，然后当你真正去追求它们时，你又会被嘲笑。但如果你不这么做，你就会被说成是懒惰、没有动力、还有着严重的权利意识。我在想，是不是人们把驱动力和野心误当成了自我，当成了自恋。但实际上，我的驱动力和野心来自于……我是说，我们现在要探讨得很深刻了。也许它来自于一种想要变得更好的渴望。也许这也源于我的成长背景，有一种“我想变得更好”的感觉，我只是想让自己每天都变得更好。看看自己究竟能变得多优秀。这其实就是在挑战自我，对吧？对啊，并不是说我什么都想要。我只是想把工作做好。看看我是不是能做得更多，或者承担更多。或者，对，这一切大概都可以归结为“挑战自我”这个主题，对吧？我是说，如果你没有这么做，我猜这里的每个人在这个方面都是一样的。比如我经常会说：“好吧，我要退休了。我只是太累了之类的话。”然后我想……比如我可以说：“好吧，我要退休了。我只是对这些东西感到太累了。”接着我又觉得，我连六个小时都坚持不下来，因为并不是说我会觉得无聊……而是我只想……生活的全部目的就是参与其中，挑战自我，并且不断地……对吧？我是说，对。希望你也能不断地拥有要求更多的勇气。因为很多时候，我都曾处于这样一种状态：噢天哪，谢天谢地，没有人要求我承担任何责任，因为我现在的自我意识或自信根本不足以让我挑起这个担子。就像我生命中有很多次都处于那种状态。如果你发现自己处于一种“不，请让电话响吧，我想要这个机会”的状态。是的。那真是一个太棒的状态了。那是一种天赋，也是一件积极的事。杰，肖恩，你想要这个机会吗？当然，两个都想要。我讨厌你们俩。杰西卡，我来问你这个，因为我最近一直在经历这种状态，也就是——你知道的，我53岁了，我觉得你看起来棒极了。你成功了。我刚才其实是在……谢谢你。我刚刚有点语无伦次。有一个评分是10分。我是说，你能看得出来你经常出入，经常健身。对，这是真的。这肤色是真的。那可不是什么便宜货，你知道的？不，这个是新晒的，顺便说一句。我觉得它更糟。我能看出来。我想我会选这个。我都忘了我是怎么弄到这个的。但我最近一直有这种感觉：我在为某些事情努力，在做一些事情，而且我能够说出口——我想我那天可能对你说过，杰——我能够承认自己其实很害怕，因为我即将去做某事……你知道的，那可能稍微有点超出我的舒适区。我觉得在我更年轻的时候，我更难承认这一点，那时候我还不够投入，或者不够成熟。我想知道你是否有过这种感受，因为你做了很多极具挑战性的事情，尤其是在你的工作方面。当你渐渐变老时，你现在也会有这样的时刻吗？你会觉得自己说：“是的，我对这个感到害怕，或者我很紧张。”并不是说你不会去做，而是你意识到了这一点，你完全有这种感觉吗？你是在问我吗？对。是的，我在乎别人的看法。我是说，这也是一种感觉……因为我觉得自己离过去的成长经历并不遥远，所以我总是希望自己能保持感激和感恩。所以我不……在我的性格中，在我骨子里，我发现懒惰是最糟糕的特质。而且我对懒惰的人也……你知道的，如果有人超级懒惰，我发现这是最糟糕的特质。而且对于懒惰……你知道的，如果有人超级懒惰，我和他们在一起会觉得很吃力，因为我觉得，哇，你本可以做成那么多事的。你本可以……你知道的，只要你肯露面，只要你愿意为自己露面，也为别人露面，外面有那么多不可思议的事情等着你参与其中。所以我的骨子里也有这种特质：哪怕我真的很害怕，只要有某个人相信我能做到，我就不想让他们失望。我真的想好好逼自己一把。我不想让任何紧张或恐惧占上风。尤其是……尤其是拍《塔米·菲的眼睛》时，我心里有那么多的恐惧，觉得“天哪，这次尝试跨度太大了，大家一定会笑话我的”。但这种想法……我不能允许……这其实就是自负，如果你允许自己的自负阻止你去尝试某件事的话。因为这全都是关于你如何被别人看待。但你觉得，对。这很有趣。但与此同时，但这算是自负吗？这算是自负吗？我在问，我其实是在琢磨。也许你们可以插话。承认这种恐惧算不算自负？这意味着这是一件好事还是一件坏事？对，就好像是在说：“嘿，这是一件极具挑战性的事情，我需要它，而且我只是意识到了这一点。”也许需要一个健康的自负，才能承认某件事对你构成了挑战。而且我认为，也正是这种相同的自负，将成为推着你跨过这道坎的动力。而且……而且你不应该因为自己缺乏冲进这种局面的自信而感到紧张，因为自信其实是在完成之后的另一面。这就好比：“不，等我熬过这一关，自信自然就有了。那才是我通过努力赢得的。”所以不要把它当作一个虚假的负面信号。如果你心里想：“天哪，我应付不了这个，因为我进去的时候一点自信都没有”，那才是一个虚假的负面信号。对我而言，自信是在事情完成之后才出现的。肯定的，肯定的。完全赞同。说得太好了。如果你在做这件事的时候信心满满，如果我也有这种感觉，那我发现这份工作大概率要砸。不会的。对，对。你太兴奋了。这倒是个好油门。对，当你觉得“太棒了，这事儿我拿下了，老兄”的时候。没错。是个好……好油门。对，当你觉得“太棒了，这事儿我拿下了，老兄”的时候。对，没错。我每次演出前都吓得要死。真的吗？真的吗？吓得半死，这才能让你变得伟大。好吧，这个我可不知道，不过我只是觉得……托尼奖得主。不，不，不，我是说……这能让你变得伟大。好吧，谢谢，不过我只是说这是真的。我不知道它是不是真的。所以我是在附和你的观点，肖恩。它们既是……谢谢，不过我只是说这是真的。我不知道它是不是真的。所以我是在附和你的观点，肖恩。我们看过这部剧。不，但是……哦等等，我本来想说的是——所以杰西卡，就像回到……当我还是个孩子的时候，我只是……我在问你，你是否有过同样的感受：当我还是个孩子的时候，你知道的，我爸爸笑了，我妈妈一直在工作。她很棒，但你基本上是被迫自己抚养自己。所以你基本上被赋予了两种选择：要么自己摸索着过完这辈子，要么就对此退居其次，逆来顺受。我觉得当时在某一个时刻，我做出的决定是：“等一下，没有人……我必须自己摸索，我必须照顾好自己，为自己把这一切搞清楚。”所以，我把这种心态带到了成年后，截至目前……而且我觉得，无论好坏，有时候往往是坏的一面，我根本停不下来。就像我必须把饭端上桌。我必须得吃，我必须……因为曾经有太多次我吃不饱饭，你知道的……所以这既是一种恐惧，也是一种驱动力。哇，我们的成长经历太相似了，肖恩。太疯狂了。值得一提的是，肖恩，你现在喂饱自己的方式和你11岁时一模一样，那就是吃太多的沙拉、薯片，然后不停地奔跑。别忘了还有那个包。太真实了。顺便说一句，在我那栋楼的拐角处，每天都有一辆冰激凌车和一个水果摊。我路过那个水果摊。对。我甚至都不敢看那个可怜的人一眼。对，杰西卡和肖恩，你们有没有发现自己其实很不擅长寻求帮助，很不擅长推卸责任或授权，因为你们太长时间以来都必须靠自己独立支撑？是的，我确实如此。我往往会把所有事情都揽下来，直到自己被彻底压垮。我想这也是因为我是家里最大的孩子，有一种必须照顾我的……我几乎想说照顾我的孩子，照顾我的兄弟姐妹的责任感。你知道的，我妈妈以前在酒吧兼职，我们就在那里，你知道的。所以这真是一种试图弄清楚……你知道的，怎样才能让每个人都平安无事的心理。所以我觉得我把这种习惯也带到了现在，尽管有时候……这真的太多了。我的朋友们就会说：“好了，冷静点，查斯坦。”但我总是试图……如果有人遇到了问题，我就会说：“好的，我们来解决它。我们来把它搞定。”我不得不去理解一件事：每个人都有按自己的方式去经历人生的尊严。我必须允许他们过自己的生活。我也太像了。这些guys都可以作证。我会说……他们会说：“嘿，我们要不要……？”我来搞定。我会说：“我来弄。我来处理。”肖恩，我们会收到一封关于某项工作事务的邮件，那可能是一封长邮件，里面大概有12个要点，大多数人看到都会觉得“我们讨论一下吧，或者考虑个24小时再说”。我甚至都不会立刻去读这封邮件。肖恩在五分钟内就会回复：“行，这个不行；行，这个可以，我们应该这么做。”我就想：“哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，行。”肖恩在五分钟内就会回复：“行，这个不行；行，这个可以，我们应该这么做。”我就想：“哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，我根本不用去考虑那件事。你知道关于告密者的事吗，你知道他们会得到什么吗？怎么了？发生了什么？嗯，就是会挨刀子，兄弟。噢，靠。抱歉，继续，杰西卡，你刚刚说什么？你发现了？我发现了，我正在跟导演聊天，他说他每天都会收到一份报告，他收到了一份报告，上面甚至精确到某个演员咳嗽了几声，上面写着演员在什么时候咳嗽了。我知道。他们把发生的每一件小事、每一个镜头都记录下来。
SmartLess is sponsored by BetterHelp. So, you know, if you listened to ads ago, you know that Scotty took me for helicopter ride. He surprised me. We've been stuck in our apartment and the theater, as you know, blah, blah, blah, blah. We haven't gone anywhere in six months. So he takes me to helicopter, and I was like, you know, not feeling great about it.
SmartLess 由 BetterHelp 赞助。所以，你知道的，如果你听过之前的广告，你就会知道斯科特带我去坐了直升机。他给了我一个惊喜。如你所知，我们一直被困在公寓和剧院里，等等等等。我们已经六个月没去过任何地方了。所以他带我去坐直升机，我当时想，你知道的，感觉不太好。
I was shaky, I was in nervous, I have an anxiety, I was like uncertain about like, what is this thing gonna do? Oh my God, you know how it is. It's like it's not fun at first and then you're up in the air, you're like, oh, I can handle this. But the takeoff is hard.
我当时直打哆嗦，很紧张，我有焦虑症，我对这一切会发生什么感到不确定。天哪，你知道那是怎样的。就像一开始并不好玩，然后你升到了空中，你会想，哦，我能应付这个。但起飞很难。
Sometimes in life, the takeoff is hard and you gotta decide if you wanna be up in the air or not-off is hard, and you've got to decide if you want to be up in the air or not, and you've got to figure out how you're going to land. Right? Maybe you're thinking about a career change, you're feeling like your relationship needs some TLC, whatever it is, therapy can help you map out your future, and trust yourself to find the way forward. I know it always helps me, and I always speak about my anxiety and everything that goes
有时在生活中，起飞很难，你必须决定是否想身处空中——起飞很难，你必须决定是否想身处空中，并且你必须弄清楚你将如何着陆。对吧？也许你在考虑转行，你觉得你的感情需要一些悉心呵护，无论是什么，心理治疗都可以帮助你规划未来，并信任自己能找到前进的道路。我知道这总是对我有帮助，我总是谈论我的焦虑以及与之相关的一切
with it, and therapy has always helped me, and I always speak about my anxiety and everything that goes with it and Therapy has always helped me and I've always turned to it It always always always helps and thinking about the helicopter experience It probably opens up, you know control issues, right? I don't know if you feel the same way if you can surrender to a plane ride or a helicopter ride or a car ride Sometimes I can't I have to but it's hard. So maybe this is something I'll discuss with my therapist. If you're thinking of starting therapy, give BetterHelp a try. It's entirely online designed to be convenient, flexible, and suited to your schedule. Just fill out a brief questionnaire to get matched with a licensed therapist and switch therapists
心理治疗一直对我有帮助，我总是谈论我的焦虑以及与之相关的一切，心理治疗一直对我有帮助，我一直向它求助。它总是、总是、总是很有帮助，回想一下直升机体验，它可能会引发，你知道的，控制欲的问题，对吧？我不知道你是否有同感，你是否能向飞机飞行、直升机飞行或汽车行驶妥协。有时我做不到，我必须这样做，但这很难。所以也许这是我会和我的治疗师讨论的事情。如果你正在考虑开始心理治疗，不妨试试 BetterHelp。它完全在线上，旨在提供便利、灵活，并适合你的日程安排。只需填写一份简短的问卷，即可与有执照的治疗师匹配，并且可以随时更换治疗师
any time for no additional charge. Let therapy be your map with BetterHelp. Visit BetterHelp.com-smartless-today to get 10% off your first month. That's BetterHelp-HELP.com slash SmartLess today to get 10% off your first month. That's BetterHelpHELP.com slash SmartLess. And now back to the show. Now what about, I like to ask actors that have had the pleasure of working with so many incredible directors. If there's any desire to direct, because you've been exposed to so much great directing, and perhaps has armed you with sort of cherry picking
无需支付额外费用。让心理治疗成为你的路线图，使用 BetterHelp。今天就访问 BetterHelp.com-smartless，首月可享 10% 的折扣。网址是 BetterHelp-HELP.com 斜杠 SmartLess，今天就可享首月 10% 的折扣。网址是 BetterHelpHELP.com 斜杠 SmartLess。现在回到节目中。话说回来，我喜欢问那些曾有幸与如此多杰出导演合作过的演员，是否有什么导演的愿望？因为你接触了如此多伟大的导演，也许这为你武装了一种精挑细选的能力
a bunch of different techniques that you'd want to see what you could do. Yeah, I mean, I've had thoughts about doing it, especially when I've met, there's certain actors that I've met and I was like, oh, I really want to do something for this person. And I've thought about, or like, I've never seen a story about this before.
许多不同的技巧，让你想看看自己能做些什么。是的，我的意思是，我有过这方面的想法，特别是当我遇到某些演员时，我想，哦，我真的很想为这个人做点什么。我曾想过，或者像，我以前从未见过这样的故事。
And I would love to tell that story. And then I think about, well, wait a minute, when you're directing, it's gonna take you a year and a half of your life, where I usually make like five films in that time. Right. You know, and so. It's a pay cut.
我很乐妇讲这个故事。然后我想，等一下，当你导演时，这会花掉你一年半的生活，而我通常在那段时间里拍五部电影。对吧。你知道，所以这相当于减薪。
Yeah, yeah. And not even that's so just that. It's also that maybe I have a sense of, in the same way of my personal, I feel like I have to do everything. I want to do everything. Wow, what's it going to be when I really have to be like, I'm only allowed to do this one thing for so long?
是啊，是啊。不仅如此。还有可能我有一种感觉，就像对待我的个人生活一样，我觉得我必须做所有事情。我想做所有事情。哇，如果我真的必须像这样——“在这么长的时间里我只被允许做这一件事”，那会是什么样子？
Yeah, Jay actually I mean this goes to both you at Jessica and Jason Do you cuz Jay you do that when you take a year to go and work on a film and direct it? Do you miss? getting that Variety and Jessica on the back side of that is do you you say you would do five films? Is that something you like you like that constant change and that backside of that is, do you, you say you would do five films? Is that something you like? You like that constant change and that kind of, that you're working on a film for three months
对啊，杰伊，其实我的意思是，这适用于你、杰西卡和杰森。杰伊，当你花一年时间去拍一部电影并担任导演时，你怀念吗？怀念那种多样性吗？杰西卡，从反面来说，你是说你会拍五部电影？你喜欢那种不断的改变吗？反过来说，杰西卡，你是说你会拍五部电影？那是你喜欢的事吗？你喜欢那种不断的改变，以及那种你为了一部电影工作三个月
and then you're working on something completely different for another three months? Do you, is that something that's your cognizant of? You go, Jessica. I would, I mean, I trained, I trained in Repetory Theater, so I love the idea and I would be amazing also in theater to be able to do this, where you're one night, you're one part,
然后又去为完全不同的事情工作另外三个月？你，你对这一点有意识吗？你说吧，杰西卡。我的意思是，我受过训练，我在剧目剧团受过训练，所以我喜欢这个想法，在剧院里能够做到这一点也会很棒，你今晚是一个角色，
and the next night you're another part. Maybe not in the same place. It's called Seymour Hoffman, and yeah, remember that. It's called Seymour Hoffman, and yeah, I remember that. Yeah, that was cool. We are theater nerds. Yeah. We're even doing different plays,
明天晚上是另一个角色。也许不在同一个地方。这就是菲利普·塞默·霍夫曼，是的，记住那个。这就是菲利普·塞默·霍夫曼，是的，我记得。对，那太酷了。我们是剧院书呆子。对。我们甚至在排不同的戏剧，
like having it ensemble, and then every night you get to do something else. I feel like that was the hard part for me of being on brought, being on this run for so long. It was the constant sense of like, this is the journey, this I'm on this journey every day. And it would be nice to kind of go on the flip side and say, like, OK, now maybe on Tuesdays, I get to do this
比如拥有一个剧团，然后每天晚上你都可以做别的事情。我觉得对我来说，在百老汇演这么长时间最难的部分是那种持续的感觉，即：这就是旅程，我每天都在这段旅程中。如果能反过来，说“好吧，也许现在周二我可以做这种事并探索别的事情”，那就好了。
kind of thing and explore something else. Well, for you and for Sean, did you guys ever get in Sean, you're still in the midst of it? You ever get to the point where it's feeling so monotonous that you are very deliberate about making tonight different. Like I'm going to play this scene jealous instead of insecure or like a completely different energy and not telling any of the other actors, but just pace and intention and everything just is still works. Well, I think the actors would really appreciate that.
好吧，对你和肖恩来说，你们有没有——肖恩，你还在其中——你们有没有遇到过这样的时刻，感觉太单调了，以至于你们非常刻意地让今晚变得不同？就像我要把这场戏演成嫉妒而不是不安全感，或者是一种完全不同的能量，而且不告诉任何其他演员，只是节奏、意图和一切仍然有效。嗯，我觉得演员们会非常赞赏这一点。
Well, it doesn't have to be 180, but something that is just changed. Does the look from your fellow actor like on the stage like, you're painting me in a corner here, man. But Jay, do you miss that? Do I? I mean, do you miss the variety? Do you miss that change when you're working for the whole for a year? No, because I just, I geek out on all the good processes of directing, you know, wrap and
嗯，倒不一定是 180 度大转弯，但就是有所改变。你的同行演员在舞台上的眼神会不会像是在说：老兄，你把我逼进死角了。不过杰伊，你怀念那个吗？我吗？我是说，你怀念多样性吗？当你一整年都在工作时，你怀念那种改变吗？不，因为我只是，我对导演的所有优秀流程感到狂热，你知道，杀青和
post and all that stuff. But, but I feel like if I was on stage doing the same part for months on end, I would, I would probably screw things up a little bit on purpose or start to get excited about, oh, who's going to forget a line tonight, you know? Yeah, because you missed that, like you miss getting that, like you could say it here, if you want the code to, you like to get strange, like to get some strange, yeah, yeah, get some strange. When it comes to code, you like to get strange. I like to get some strange. Yeah, yeah, yeah, some strange. When it comes to work, we got to work.
后期制作以及所有这些东西。但是，如果我在舞台上连续几个月扮演同一个角色，我想我可能会故意把事情搞砸一点，或者开始对“今晚谁会忘词”感到兴奋，你知道吗？对，因为你怀念那种——你怀念那种感觉，就像你可以在这里说的那样，如果你想要暗号，你喜欢玩点刺激的，喜欢来点刺激的，对，对，来点刺激的。说到暗号，你喜欢玩点刺激的。我喜欢来点刺激的。对，对，对，来点刺激的。说到工作，我们必须工作。
What about, yes, the animal, dude? What about Jessica? What about that? What Jason was saying? I've worked with someone who was like that. It's frustrating to work with someone. I mean, on film, it's great. It's great.
那这个呢，动物，老兄？杰西卡呢？杰森刚才说的那种情况呢？我曾和那样的人合作过。和那样的人合作很让人沮丧。我的意思是，在电影里，这很棒。这真的很棒。
You know what, like, with actors, you're like, it's still the same scene, but there's all these, we're just covering new's still the same scene, but there's all these, we're discovering new paths through the scene, and who knows where the takes gonna go. That's exciting. But if you like, when the show is set, it's set. And-
你知道的，就像，对于演员来说，你会觉得，这仍然是同一场戏，但有所有这些，我们只是在覆盖新——这仍然是同一场戏，但有所有这些，我们正在发现通过这场戏的新途径，谁知道拍摄会走向何方。这很令人兴奋。但是如果你喜欢，当节目排定后，它就是排定了。而且——
Two disruptive. Yeah, I would, sometimes when someone's done, it feels kind of almost self-serving, because it's like, well, wait a minute, there's still a whole other journey. We have to go on, and now you've kind of taken out this marker, how are we going to get there? That would be a fun war to watch.
太具有破坏性了。是的，我会觉得，有时当某人这么做时，感觉几乎是自私的，因为就像，等一下，还有一整段旅程我们要走，而你现在却拿出了这个记号，我们怎么才能到达那里？看这场大战一定很有趣。
If you were privy to it by being another cast member and you can watch too, like, oh, she's just wrecking. She just saw that he's trying to do a 180 on this thing. Oh, and now she's going to double that 180. Yeah, yeah, yeah. And then who chastises an actor, the stage manager? Yeah, usually. They're sort of the cop manager? Yeah, usually.
如果你作为另一个演员也参与其中，你也可以观看，比如，哦，她简直是在搞砸。她刚看到他想在这件事上做 180 度大转弯。哦，现在她要将那个 180 度翻倍。对，对，对。然后是谁来惩罚演员，舞台经理吗？对，通常是。他们有点像警察——经理吗？对，通常是。
They're sort of the cop that's ongoing, right? Because if you, I don't think a listener knows this, but if you start messing around with the dialogue, you get like reported to equity and equity can find you. If you start messing around with changing lines and stuff like that, I don't know about that. I think stage managers like obligated to report you if you start going rogue and changing stuff.
他们有点像一直在那里的警察，对吧？因为如果你，我觉得听众可能不知道这一点，但如果你开始搞乱台词，你会被举报给演员工会，工会可以罚款你。如果你开始搞乱台词之类的东西，我不太清楚这个。我觉得舞台经理好像有义务在你开始不守规矩并乱改东西时举报你。
It sounds like you snitched before, did you? Yeah, but I just didn't have to think about that. You know the thing about snitches, you know what they get? What happened? What happened? Well, it just gets stitches, bro. Oh, shit.
听起来你以前告密过，是吗？对，但我只是不需要去想那个。你知道关于告密者的事吗？你知道他们会得到什么吗？发生什么了？发生什么了？嗯，就是会挨针缝，老兄。哦，靠。
Sorry, go ahead, Jessica, you what happened? You found out? I found out, I was talking to the director and he said that every night he gets a report, he got a report because where it was like even like when an actor coughs, it said when the actor coughs. I know. They write down every single thing that happens in every shot.
抱歉，请继续，杰西卡，你发生了什么？你被发现了？我被发现了，我当时在和导演谈话，他说他每天都会收到一份报告，他收到了一份报告，上面甚至连演员什么时候咳嗽都写进去了。我知道。他们记下了每次拍摄中发生的每一件小事。
Yeah. Yeah. And the producers get to read it. Yeah. Yeah. So you're very aware. I mean, it's tough sometimes. I do find like in, there's a misconception about acting where someone's like, okay, the
对。对。而且制作人们都能看到。对。所以你得时刻保持清醒。我是说，有时候这真的很难。我发现有时候人们对表演存在一种误解，觉得……
more different they are, each take, the better actor they are because they're so alive, you know? And so I think people are trying to be sometimes make things alive and exciting and, but they don't realize in the theater that that can be disrupter. Yeah. Well, yeah, and in film too and Jay, you've been through this. I've certainly been through this in, in, in post where you're Well, yeah, and in film too, and Jay, you've been through this. I've certainly been through this in, in, in post where you're like, Hey, did this guy ever do
每个镜头表现得越不一样，说明他们是个好演员，因为他们太有生命力了，你知道吗？所以我觉得人们有时候总是试图让事情显得生动刺激，但他们没有意识到，在戏剧舞台上，这种做法可能会起到破坏作用。对，没错。而且在电影里也是这样，杰，你经历过这个。我当然也在后期制作中经历过……
one fucking take where he held the thing the same way two times? Oh, yeah. I'm not telling me. I can't get out. I can't fucking edit the scene. What is he doing? But it's okay. Like Jay, to what you were saying, I think it's okay in a play to play within the choices that are locked. Yes. You know, within the play that is locked, you can experiment, but not enough to, like there's this great, and there's this John Girejewski
哦，对，在电影里也是这样，杰，你经历过这个。我当然也在后期制作中经历过，当时你会想：“嘿，这家伙拍戏时有没有哪怕有一次，把拿道具的动作保持得跟两次一模一样？”哦，对。别告诉我。我没法剪辑。我剪不了这个场景。他到底在干嘛？但没关系。就像杰你刚才说的，我觉得在一部戏剧里，在锁定的台词和调度范围内去进行表演是完全可以的。是的。你知道的，在锁定的剧本范围内，你可以进行实验，但绝不能过头，就像有一位伟大的……还有约翰·格雷杰夫斯基，
who plays George Gershwin or a play. He's brilliant, everybody's brilliant in the show. But he's so great at playing within the locked thing. He's brilliant. And one night, it almost made me laugh. He goes, Oki, you know, Oscar, who wants to hear your music, right? And I say, he's a vision in my head. He's a ghost, the ghost of Gershwin.
他在一部戏里扮演乔治·格什温。他太棒了，剧里的每个人都很棒。但他太擅长在既定的框架内进行表演了。他简直绝了。有一次，我差点笑出声来。他说：“奥基，你知道的，奥斯卡，谁想听你的音乐，对吧？”然后我说：“他是印在我脑海里的幻影。他是个鬼魂，格什温的鬼魂。”
And I say lots of folks, that's who. And he goes, and the line is, who? Your wife, the kid in the lab coat, right? And one night, he goes out of nowhere. He goes, I go, he goes, who wants to hear you, that your own music? I go lots of folks that's doing, he goes, who? He got your wife, he got your kid in the lab coat.
然后我说：“有的是人想听，这就是谁。”接着他说——台词本来应该是：“谁？你老婆，还有那个穿着实验服的小屁孩，对吧？”结果有一天，他突然即兴来了一句。他说……我说，他说：“谁想听你的音乐，听你自己的音乐？”我说：“有的是人想听，这就是。”他说：“谁？”他说：“你老婆，还有你那个穿着实验服的小屁孩。”
And then he just goes like this. Right. And almost, it almost made me die laughing. Oh my God. But it was good, because it was within the realm of the character. But like he was listening, I mean, your wife, no lab coat.
然后他就做了个这样的表情。对。而且差点……差点让我笑死。天哪。但这种即兴很棒，因为它完全符合角色的设定。而且他一直在倾听，我是说……你老婆，没有穿实验服。
And I was, yeah. Michael Shannon's really good at that too. I've worked with him a lot. And mostly on camera. So he doesn't go, working with him is like, it's like kind of working with an animal because you're like, what is he gonna do? But it's always within the structure
然后我就……是的。迈克尔·香农在这方面也很厉害。我和他合作过很多次。而且大多是在镜头前。所以他不会按常理出牌，跟他合作感觉就像……就像跟一头野兽合作一样，因为你根本不知道他下一步要做什么。但他的发挥总是牢牢根植于结构之中的，
and he comes from theater as well. And it's really like, it's amazing when you're working with an actor who knows where the story has to be the most important. It's not yourself. That's what it is. It's about whether or not you're selfish, because if you're changing it for yourself,
而且他也是演话剧出身的。真的……当你和一个懂得“故事本身才是最重要的，而不是你自己”的演员合作时，那种感觉简直绝了。事情就是这样。关键在于你是不是自私，如果你改变表演纯粹是为了满足自己，
because you want to feel something new or your board, that's not appropriate. But if you're telling, you have to tell the story that everyone's there to tell. Exactly. I killed Michael Shannon in a movie once. Oh, you did? In a movie once.
因为你想体验某种新的感觉或者你觉得无聊了，那可就不合适了。但如果你在讲故事，你就必须讲好大家来到这里共同要讲的故事。没错。我有一次在电影里把迈克尔·香农给杀了。哦，是吗？在一部电影里。
Yeah. With a gun? No, no, no, I stabbed him in the throat. Oh. You said that Michael Shannon, I stabbed them in the throat. Oh, Michael. In the throat in the throat in let's go to prison 20 years ago with the Michael. That's right. Bob loaded Kirk. Bob. How did he take that? Like a man. Took it pretty well. I remember Bob being like, okay, so Michael. Oh my God. So you're just going to grab him like, wait, how are we going to do this? Like Michael is so scary. He's
用枪吗？不，不，不，我一刀捅了他的喉咙。哦。你刚才说迈克尔·香农，我说我捅了他的喉咙。哦，迈克尔。在喉咙上，在喉咙上，在……那是20年前的电影《送我上法庭》，和迈克尔一起。没错。鲍勃·奥登科克。鲍勃。他当时反应如何？像个真正的男人。他接受得挺坦然的。我记得鲍勃当时说：“好吧，所以迈克尔……”天哪。所以你打算直接抓住他，等等，我们该怎么演？迈克尔太吓人了。他
the best at. He's such a great guy. But I was like, I have to stab we gonna do this thing? Like, Michael is so scary as to the best act. He's such a great guy. But I was like, I have to stab him in the throat and he did all the work. I just kind of did the motion. He was incredible. A bunch of apologizing before he was the best. I feel like we'll be remiss if we don't ask it.
是最棒的。他是个超级大好人。但我当时想：我得捅他的喉咙，而且所有的重活累活都是他干的。我只是做了个假动作。他太不可思议了。在开拍前一顿疯狂道歉，他真的是最棒的。我觉得如果我们不问那个问题，就太失职了。
I'm gonna ask, usually Sean at this point, has already asked, you've done so much theater. Oh, yes. What's your favorite nightmare? Theater, how did you not ask Jessica Chessney? Oh, if I? I'm not asking. Oh, God. My favorite nightmare story that happened to me on stage. Yeah. All right. I can say it now because we're closed. This is really gross. Great. When I will tell you that. Gross or the bed. I threw up. What? What? In a doll's house? I threw up and I swallowed it. No! God! That a girl.
我要问了，通常肖恩在这个时候，已经问过了——你演过那么多戏剧。哦，对。你经历过的最可怕的噩梦是什么？演戏剧时，你怎么能不问杰西卡·查斯坦呢？哦，我吗？我才不问呢。哦，天哪。我在舞台上经历过的最可怕的噩梦。好吧。我现在可以说了，因为这期节目快结束了。这真的太恶心了。太好了。是恶心还是……我吐了。什么？什么？在《玩偶之家》里？我吐了，然后又把它咽下去了。不！天哪！真不愧是我认识的女孩。
No way! And no one knew. And then... Because acid reflux is something? No, it's a bad performance. I was like, I was like, what's the same? I think I, and then from then on, I was like, I'm not eating within three hours of the show.
绝不可能！而且根本没人发现。然后……因为胃酸倒流什么的？不，是因为那天演砸了。我当时就想……我当时想：“这演的什么鬼啊？”然后从那以后，我在演出前三个小时内绝对不吃任何东西。
Same water. Yeah, it's crazy. Wait, what happened? I don't know if I was nervous. I was like, it's kind of like sobbing. I leaned over and it happened. And then for the rest, and I was like, oh my God, you can't let it out of your mouth. And then for the rest of the show,
同样的事情也发生在喝水上。对，这太疯狂了。等等，后来怎么了？我不知道我当时是不是太紧张了。就感觉……有点像在抽泣。我把身子一倾，然后就吐了。然后接下来的时间里，我当时想：“哦，天哪，你绝对不能让它从嘴里吐出来。”然后接下来的整场演出，
I couldn't tell anyone, because I was on his chair facing the audience the whole time. You have any intimate scenes after that? I had to kiss someone. Sure. No. Yes, yes, it was a nightmare. And I couldn't explain. And in the second we had the curtain call.
我都不能告诉任何人，因为我整场戏都坐在一把正对着观众的椅子上。你之后还有亲密戏吗？我得去亲一个人。当然。没有。有，有的，那真是一场噩梦。而且我根本无法解释。就在我们谢幕的那一秒钟，
And the curtain came down. I said, you guys, I'm so sorry, I vomited. That's so crazy, because Jason, didn't you ever think for a long time that women would barf after they kissed you, right? No, no, no. Yeah, which is better. Yeah, that's what I'm saying. just because that's what I'm saying.
大幕刚落下。我对大家说：“伙计们，实在对不起，我刚才吐了。”这太疯狂了，因为杰森，你以前不是一直觉得女演员跟你接吻后都会想吐吗？不，不，不。对，这倒没有。好吧，这倒也是。杰西卡，这就是我想说的。
Was it, was it an open mouth kiss that you had to do on stage? No, that night it was definitely a closed mouth kiss. Well, you know, you know, it used to be kind of like, it wasn't essential. It wasn't like a really sexy like we're about to sleep, you know, but it was, you know, a sensual kiss that was in that night. I was like, oh, I mean, even talking to anyone, I was just so... Oh, my God.
那是……那是你在舞台上必须得演的法式热吻吗？不，那天晚上的绝对是个礼貌的闭嘴吻。好吧，你知道的，你知道以前那种感觉就像……这并不是那么必不可少。这不像是一场极其性感的、感觉我们马上就要上床的那种戏，你知道的，但那是一个挺感性的吻。那天晚上，我当时就想：噢……哪怕是跟任何人说话，我都觉得……天哪。
I have to, in the show, I have to stand a scream in front of this guy. Peter Gross, who's a brilliant, also brilliant in the show. And we get in a screaming match and we're literally nose to nose. And one night, I don't know what happened. It was just like a couple of weeks ago.
我在演出中必须站在这个家伙面前大喊大叫。彼得·格罗斯，他是个才华横溢的人，在剧里也是个天才。我们当时在激烈地争吵，而且脸几乎都要贴到一块儿去了。结果有一天，我也不知道怎么回事。大概就是几个星期前吧。
So much saliva came spuing from my mouth. It was all over his face as I'm talking about. And then that night after he goes, he was so sweet about, he goes, hey, can I touch you with that one? Oh, okay. And I go, yeah, he goes, is there any way that you could spit
我的嘴里喷出了好多的唾沫。我说话的时候，口水喷了他一脸。然后那天演出结束后，他特别温柔地说——他真是个大好人——他说：“嘿，待会儿我能碰你一下吗？”哦，好吧。然后我说：“行啊。”他说：“我们吵架的时候，你能不能……少喷哪怕一点点口水？”我当时就说：“没问题。绝对没问题。”他对待这事儿简直太温柔了。这就像是一场喷嚏大爆炸，对吧？而且这真的很好笑，因为这显然不是你能控制的。并不是说他心里在想：“哦，我要大闹一场，好好发挥一下。”不，是不是这样的，但是……
just a little less when we argue? I was like, absolutely. Absolutely. He was so sweet about it. It was like a tick explosion, right? Even it's really funny because it's obviously not something you had control over. It wasn't like he thought, like, oh, I'm going to really go to town and say. No, was that, but-
当我们争吵时，少了一点？我当时想，绝对的。绝对的。他对此真是太友好了。就像是一场抽搐大爆发，对吧？甚至这真的很搞笑，因为它显然不是你能控制的事情。并不是他觉得，哦，我要大干一场然后说。不，是那样，但是——
But you- But it's a lie about all over his face tonight. No, no, but he was right. I actually can control it now. Now that he's brought it up, I actually figured it out. Let me ask you, if he hadn't brought it up, would you have continued doing it? Great question. Spitting that much?
但你——但这全写在他今晚的脸上了，这绝对是谎话。不，不，但他没说错。其实我现在能控制了。既然他提出来了，我其实已经想通了。我问你，如果他没提出来，你还会继续这样做吗？问得好。吐得那么多吗？
Yeah. Probably not. I know what he meant. I know what he meant. I was like, I'm sorry, I'm sorry, I was like spitting out. Oh my God, Purga's covered in sloppy Joe and Xin Xin. Sean, you get Xininshin flown out. Sorry, go ahead, Justin.
对。可能不会。我懂他的意思。我懂他的意思。我当时就想，抱歉，抱歉，我当时就吐出来了。天哪，普尔加身上沾满了碎肉汉堡和新新。肖恩，你得把新新接过来。抱歉，你继续，贾斯廷。
That's the point. I was just going to ask Jessica. Now that the show is done, you're going to take some time off. I would assume you're going to start doing the thing your second best at, which is probably as good, probably a lot of parenting. But like, what about the, what is there hobby? Is there something that we would be surprised to learn that you're almost at a good backstage? Yeah, no, I'm not going to anything else. That's the thing.
就是这样。我正想问杰西卡。既然演出结束了，你要休息一段时间。我想你接下来要开始做你排第二擅长的事了，可能也做得很好，那就是带娃。不过话说回来，有什么爱好吗？有没有什么事，如果我们发现你在幕后其实也挺擅长，会觉得很惊讶？对，不，我什么都不会做。这就是问题所在。
Come on, that's not true. I mean, I have a production company and, and that doesn't count. And we're talking about some of this outside of the industry. Like, we're talking aboutball, painting, baking. Okay, I went to cooking school. What? Yes. Yeah, I went to school. So after zero dark 30, I was like,
拜托，才不是这样。我是说，我有一家制作公司，而，这不算。我们说的是行业之外的事。比如，我们说的是打球、画画、烘焙。好吧，我去过烹饪学校。什么？对。对，我上过学。所以在拍完《猎杀本·拉登》之后，我就在想，
I wonder if something completely different. I went to cooking school. And so I'm a good cook. What kind of cooking? Kind of a process. Like, I like, I like, I like roasting. And I like the kind of cooking that the whole house, it's like a slow cook situation.
我想做点完全不同的事。我去过烹饪学校。所以我很会做饭。做什么类型的菜？有点像慢炖。比如，我喜欢，我喜欢烤制。我喜欢那种能让整间屋子都弥漫香味的烹饪，就像慢炖那种。
So for hours, it'll be like the smell of something like, I love poached pears with sweet potato ice cream and you know, that kind of stuff. Oh, it sounds good. You make the ice cream? Yeah. Really? I like the fall cooking. You know, that kind of like it's starting to get cold outside. Yeah, yeah. And then yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, a real super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super super with Jesse Boo. Just that's the title. Jesse Boo. Yeah, that's your title. Okay.
所以要炖好几个小时，就会飘散出某种香味，我喜欢红酒梨配红薯冰淇淋，你知道的，诸如此类。哦，听起来不错。冰淇淋是你做的吗？对。真的吗？我喜欢秋季的烹饪。你知道的，那种外面开始变冷的天气。对，对。然后，对，对，对，对……与杰西·布一起。标题就叫这个。杰西·布。对，这就是你的标题。好吧。
I don't know that it would be super interesting to watch, especially if it's like, it's be like a four hour show where you're just like, let's look at it in the oven. No, but if you did, but if you did, if you did like a book, if you did like a cookbook and did some stuff and did a line of food, I think it would do real, real well. All right. All right. Well, maybe that's my second chapter. And you can call it like Juke, right?
我不知道这看起来会不会很有意思，尤其是如果这是一个四小时的节目，而你只是在盯着烤箱看。不，但如果你这么做了，但如果你这么做了，如果你写了一本书，如果你出了一本食谱并做了一些东西，还推出了一个食品系列，我觉得一定会非常非常成功。好吧。好吧。好吧，也许这是我的第二人生篇章。你可以把它叫做“Juke”，对吧？
J-O-O-C, kind of like Goop, but you know. Juke, after talking about vomiting on the stage, I could open with that and then say, listen, it's so good you could, no, I don't. Oh my God. It's so good you can do twice. There you go. We've got it. Oh my God. Listen's so good. You can do it twice. There you go. We've got it.
J-O-O-C，有点像Goop，不过你懂的。Juke，在谈论在舞台上呕吐之后，我可以以此开场，然后说，听着，它太好吃了，你甚至可以……不，我才不。天哪。它太好吃了，你可以吃两份。就是这样。我们搞定了。天哪。听着，太好吃了。你可以吃两份。就是这样。我们搞定了。
Oh my God. Listen, we have monopolized, I just realized we could have just, we could just keep talking, but we're crushing you in time and you need to go on vacation. Yeah. Thank you for visiting with us, Jessica. Yeah, Jessica, thank you so much. I was so happy to, to, when I got asked to do this, I of course listened to the Cape Blanchette one. And I love how much y'all teased Sean
天哪。听着，我们把时间都占了，我刚意识到我们本来可以，我们本来可以一直聊下去，但我们严重压缩了你的时间，你还得去度假。对。谢谢你来和我们聊天，杰西卡。对，杰西卡，非常感谢。我当时非常高兴，当我被邀请做这个节目时，我当然听了凯特·布兰切特那一期。我很喜欢你们俩疯狂调侃肖恩
for being as equally as theater nerdy as all of us. He's such a good guy. I love that. With a big smile. He's not just theater nerdy. He's everything nerdy, is it true? Yeah. So if you have any Star Wars questions for him?
觉得他也和我们一样是个戏剧极客。他真是个好人。我太喜欢了。带着灿烂的笑容。他可不只是戏剧极客。他是全方位的极客，对吧？对。所以如果你有什么关于《星球大战》的问题想问他？
Yeah. I love that. Or Star Trek. Or battle Star Galactica. Any of the stars, although I will say this, this is what I wanted to ask you. Before you let you go, spring up Star Wars and stuff, you've done a few, I'm going to say science fiction, not really, but in that realm, I mean, you interstellar Martian, some of the bigger ones that fought, right? I mean, I know, me too.
对。我太喜欢了。或者《星际迷航》。或者《太空堡垒卡拉狄加》。任何关于“星”的作品，不过我要说的是，这就是我想问你的。在你走之前，聊到《星球大战》之类的，你演过几部，我要说是科幻片，虽然不太算，但属于那个领域，我是说，《星际穿越》、《火星救援》，其中一些规模较大的作品，对吧？我是说，我知道，我也是。
We were just saying yesterday how much, it's my 14 year old's favorite film. He's seen it 30 times. Do you like that genre? Because you've done a bunch on the highest level. Yeah. I mean, in fact, after I did Interstellar, I got to work with Kip Thorne on that, which was amazing. And even trying to, at the end, like writing the equation and all that stuff. That was obviously a lot of work to try to look like.
我们昨天还在说，这绝对是我14岁儿子最喜欢的电影。他已经看30遍了。你喜欢这种类型片吗？因为你演过好几部最高水准的。对。我是说，事实上，拍完《星际穿越》后，我有幸和吉普·索恩合作，这太棒了。甚至在最后尝试去写公式之类的东西。那显然需要做很多功课，才能看起来
That was believable at all. But then when I finished that and Rid, Ridley Scott came up to me and approached me about doing the Martian. I said, yeah, here's my thing though. If I sign on, I want to go to Space Camp. And he goes, there's not really adult space camp. And I was like, well, we can make one. So I went to Houston. I want to go to Space Camp. And he goes, there's not really adult space camp. And I was like, well, we can make one. So I went to Houston.
至少有些可信度。但当我拍完那部作品后，雷德利·斯科特找到我，向我谈起出演《火星救援》的事。我说，行，不过我的条件是：如果我签约，我要去太空训练营。他说，其实并没有成人的太空训练营。我说，我们可以建一个。所以我去了休斯顿。我要去太空训练营。他说，其实并没有成人的太空训练营。我说，我们可以建一个。所以我去了休斯顿。
I want to do this. It's in Austin, Houston. And I went to JPL. And I saw the rovers. I've been there, yes. It's amazing. Amazing. And I did the whole virtual reality where you're on Mars.
我想做这个。在奥斯丁，在休斯顿。我去了喷气推进实验室。我看到了火星车。我去过那里，是的。太棒了。太棒了。我还体验了全真虚拟现实，就像身处火星一样。
On Mars? You can walk? Yes. Oh my god, I did the same thing. Yeah. And so I was really, I'm excited to do things. But you know what what the film or the project is going to be when it finishes. But I just want to know that the experience of making something is going to be enriching in some way to my life.
在火星上？你能走路？对。天哪，我也体验过同样的东西。对。所以我真的很，我很兴奋能做各种尝试。但你知道电影或项目杀青时会是什么样。我只是想确保创作的过程在某种程度上能让我的生活变得更加丰富。
And so that was really, yeah, I mean, if someone wants to give me another sci-fi space movie, I don't know. I mean, are you a fan of of the genre? Like are you a like Star Wars Star Trek? No, okay. Oh, Jessica, thank you so much for being here. I am one of Space in Reality. I am one of Space in reality. I am one of Space in reality. You know, Sean, are you crying? Yeah, I'm sorry.
所以确实是这样，如果有人想再给我一部科幻太空电影，我不知道。我是说，你是这种类型片的粉丝吗？比如你是《星球大战》、《星际迷航》的粉丝吗？不，好吧。哦，杰西卡，非常感谢你能来。我是太空与现实的粉丝。我是太空与现实的粉丝。我是太空与现实的粉丝。你知道吗，肖恩，你哭了吗？对，不好意思。
Get a shot. I know I did my very good friend Oscar Isaac did all the star, and I, you know, I'm not. I like it when it's, when it feels like it could, it's happened or it's really comfortable. Well, don't worry, Jessica, I'm not a huge fan. I'm with you. Yeah, but I like Game of Thrones and there's dragons there. So I'm all over the place.
来个特写。我知道我的好朋友奥斯卡·伊萨克演了所有的《星战》，而我，你知道，我不是。我喜欢那种感觉真实发生过，或者非常贴近现实的作品。好吧，别担心，杰西卡，我也不是死忠粉。我和你一样。对，但我喜欢《权力的游戏》，里面有龙。所以我各种类型都看。
That works for me. Sure. The great Jessica Chessane. Thank you so much for joining us. Nice guys. I want to play a wonderful surprise to see you again. Yeah, thank you, Jessica. All right, what do I do?
那对我挺受用的。当然。伟大的杰西卡·查斯坦。非常感谢你加入我们。大家都很棒。能再次见到你真是个巨大的惊喜。对，谢谢你，杰西卡。好了，我该怎么做？
Do I cover my mic? Do I get out of here? Just slam it shut. If you want. Bye guys. Congratulations, Sean. Thank you so much for this. Thank you.
我要挡住麦克风吗？我要离开这儿吗？直接啪地关掉就行。如果你想的话。拜拜，各位。恭喜你，肖恩。非常感谢。谢谢。
Bye, Jessica. Thanks. Wow. Will. I know. Classed it up a little bit. Classed it up. Yeah.
再见，杰西卡。谢谢。哇。威利。我知道。稍微提升了一下格调。提升了格调。对。
Yeah. I mean, how would it surprise? I mean, I just literally saw her yesterday or two days ago Two months ago two months ago Sean is still a while I just I need to You know love show business. I know how funny right Sean that we had Jessica could you guys spend so much time you saw all the time So much time again over on Broadway always saw her always you're always so pleasant always so sweet and You know I found out she's so I get it who wouldn't, she was always so pleasant, always so sweet. And I, you know, I found out.
对。我是说，这怎么能不算惊喜呢？我是说，我昨天或前天才刚见过她。两个月前，两个月前。肖恩还是老样子。我需要，你知道，热爱演艺圈。你知道有多搞笑吗，肖恩，我们有杰西卡……你们俩花那么多时间在一起，你一直都能看到她。花了那么多时间，在百老汇也总能看到她，她总是那么随和，总是那么甜美。然后，你知道，我发现她那么……我懂，谁不会呢，她总是那么随和，总是那么甜美。然后，你知道，我发现
She's so, I get it, who wouldn't have found out? She's so accomplished and she's so good at what she does. Yeah, there's not a lot of, you know, back to that juliar thing, you do always think, I was, you know, I was just think you're set. Yeah. If you're a juliar, you're set. And like, she's one of those people that made that happen. What a talent.
她那么……我懂，谁能不这么觉得呢？她取得了如此巨大的成就，而且她做每件事都那么出色。对，没有多少那种，回到朱莉娅学院的话题，你总会觉得，我之前，你知道，我总觉得你只要从那毕业就稳了。对。如果你是朱莉娅学院毕业的，你就稳了。而且，她就是那种把这一切变成现实的人。真是个天才。
I know. you've seen Sorry, I just wanted to cut you off, but did you see George and Tammy? No, the thing we're talking with with her and Michael Shannon. Yeah, incredible I know it's about it's about Tammy. Why not in George Jones? Yeah, and she is she they're both so good at it so so so good and so such unbelievable talent. And yeah, it's really, really, really good. I can see you. And the season one's already happened. I think it's season two's coming out or something.
我知道。你看过……抱歉，我打断你一下，你看过《乔治和塔米》吗？没有，就是我们讨论过的她和迈克尔·珊农主演的那部。对，太不可思议了。我知道，讲的是塔米的故事。为什么不是乔治·琼斯呢？对，她演得，他们俩在里面都太棒了，真的太棒了，简直是不知所云的才华。而且，真的，真的，真的很好看。我能理解你。第一季已经播出了。我想第二季快要出了还是怎么的。
And I want to catch up. I don't know. It's amazing and just, I don't know. Anyway, she's, she what a delight. Yeah, easy. She seems like easy to hang out with too. Sean, and I loved how much you, you and she have sort of a similar trajectories in
我想把它补完。我不知道。太棒了，而且，我不知道。总之，她，她真是个令人愉快的演员。对，很简单。她看起来也很容易相处。肖恩，我很喜欢你和她之间似乎有某种相似的发展轨迹，那就是
that. And that wild. Yeah. I had no idea. We didn't really get into it. I'm not. When I saw her, there was never time to like, how was your childhood, you know, until I mean, when you were doing like press stuff for your plays, you weren't like, hey, I would
太疯狂了。真的吗？我完全不知道。我们之前没深入聊过这个。我不是。我见到她的时候，从来没时间去聊诸如“你的童年是怎样的”之类的话题，直到……我是说，当你们为各自的话剧做宣传时，你们不会说，“嘿，你
did you also have five brothers and sisters? And did you grab the signal? Like, yeah, we didn't get into that. No, that would have been weird, dude. I know. Maybe if you just done the small effort of walking across the street or next door and seen her fucking show, I wish I could, but I mean, you could have, because you had, well, now she's going to see you're you had Tuesday nights and you could have, I did it Tuesday night. But I want you could have gone. Yeah, what we did on Tuesday night, aside from just warming donuts in your toe. So one of the last time you weren't be honest.
是不是也有五个兄弟姐妹？你有没有抢到过信号？”对，我们没聊过这些。没有，那样就太奇怪了，老兄。我知道。也许如果你稍微花点力气，走到街对面或者隔壁去看看她那该死的演出——我希望我能去，但我是说，你本可以去的，因为你有……好吧，现在她会知道了……你周二晚上有空，你本可以……我周二晚上有演出。但我希望你本可以去的。对，我们在周二晚上除了把甜甜圈在烤面包机里加热之外还能干嘛。上一次你……说实话。
Warm the donut. When's the last time you cut a donut open, right? You just butterfly it, scooped it and toasted it in your toe. So how good is that sound? Sometimes there's donuts that work. Sometimes people bring donuts and you do the half thing where you just, I'm just going to be I'm just going to need half. I'm going to have need half a bottle.
把甜甜圈加热。你上一次把甜甜圈切开是什么时候？对，你把它像蝴蝶一样切开，挖空，然后在烤面包机里烤一下。这听起来多棒啊？有时候有些甜甜圈就是很好吃。有时候人们会带甜甜圈来，然后你只切一半，心想“我只要一半就行了。我只需要半个”。
I know. And then a half hour later. Oh, when they're flipped open and there's like a there's a plastic knife left in there. And people just got little pieces off it. Yeah. And then it's the same person comes back and just finishes it. It's five times. That's why we got the Tim Bitts. Hey, oh, yeah, yeah, if you're going to Tim, he's just going to be great. I see the Tim Burton's all the time. Oh, there's a good
我知道。然后半小时后。哦，当它们被切开，里面还留着一把塑料刀的时候。大家就会从上面掰一小块下来吃。对。然后同一个人又回来把它吃完。吃了五次。这就是我们买Tim Bitts的原因。哦，对，对，如果你要去Tim's，那太棒了。我经常看到Tim Bits。哦，有个好东西
a. So good. I can't get some. Turkey. Yeah, I honestly, the thing is what's great about the Tim bit. Here comes a bite. It's just you don't have to eat the whole thing. It's just one one. Smart. Smart.
啊。太棒了。我得吃几个。火鸡。对，老实说，Tim Bits最棒的地方在于——咬一口来咯。你不需要吃完整的一个。就一个，一个。聪明。聪明。
Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart.
聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。
Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Michael Grant Terry, Rob Armjarv, and Bennett Barberco. [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ Smart, less! This episode was recorded on June 13th. Our next episode will be out in a week wherever you listen to podcasts, or you can listen to it right now, early on Amazon music, or early and ad-free by subscribing to Wondry Plus in Apple podcasts,
聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。迈克尔·格兰特·特里、罗布·阿姆扎夫和贝内特·巴尔科。[♪ 片尾曲播放 ♪] [♪ 聪明，少即是多！]本集录制于6月13号。我们的下一期节目将在下周发布，你可以在你收听播客的任何平台上听到，或者你现在就可以在亚马逊音乐（Amazon Music）上提前收听，也可以通过订阅苹果播客（Apple Podcasts）上的Wondery Plus
or the Wondri app. properties across the country, like the Plaza and the Waldorf Historia, but their unchallenged rise wouldn't last. An ambitious Mormon named J.W. Marriott decides to pivot from restaurants to hospitality, and he's after Hilton's business, developing modern hotels across the world, but both the Hilton and Marriott families will have to contend with their share of drama in finding a successor, while also fighting to stay solvent in a high stakes business. Hi, I'm David Brown, the host of Wonderree Show Business Wars. We go deep into some of the biggest corporate rivalries of all time.
或Wondery App来提前收听且无广告版。全国各地的标志性酒店，比如广场酒店和华尔道夫酒店，但他们不可一世的崛起并未能持续。一个名叫J.W.万豪的雄心勃勃的摩门教徒决定将业务从餐厅转向酒店业，他紧追希尔顿不放，在世界各地开发现代化酒店，但希尔顿和万豪家族都将面临各自的戏剧性考验，以寻找继承人，同时还要在竞争激烈的商业世界中艰难求生，力求维持偿债能力。嗨，我是大卫·布朗，Wondery节目《商业之争》的主持人。我们将深入探讨史上一些规模最大的企业竞争。
In our latest season, Hilton and Marriott are in a race to expand globally and secure the loyalty of fickle customers. Make sure to follow business wars wherever you get your podcasts. You can listen ad-free on the Amazon Music or Wonderree app. of fickle customers. Make sure to follow business wars wherever you get your podcasts. You can listen ad free on the Amazon Music or Wondery app. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
在我们的最新一季中，希尔顿和万豪正展开一场争夺全球扩张以及反复无常的客户忠诚度的竞赛。请在各大播客平台关注《商业之争》。你可以在亚马逊音乐或Wondery App上收听无广告版。反复无常的客户忠诚度。请在各大播客平台关注《商业之争》。你可以在亚马逊音乐或Wondery App上收听无广告版。本集暂无评论。点击字幕中的任意句子即可发表评论。